it's a cash shop I love the cash app I
really do they are the best their number
one finance app on the App Store you
guys know cash app you know cash app
because number one they sponsor the most
bomb-ass podcasts but it's also the
easiest way to spend money and send
money to friends but catch-up this way
more than that cash up also comes with
the cash card what is it bet it's a free
debit card that comes with boost which
are like instant rewards for shopping in
places you already love you can get up
to 10% off your entire purchase a door -
and even save every time you shop at
Whole Foods just reading that that's my
reading voice - job is the easiest way
to try and grow your money with their
new investing feature unlike investing
tools that force you to buy entire
shares of stock that's impressive
cash app instead lets you instantly
invest as little or as much as you want
this way you can still own a piece of
any stock for just one dueler brokerage
service brokerage services brokerage
they're provided by cash app invent I'm
not I'm asking you kept investing it's a
subsidiary of square and member simf2p
one of my favorite organizations it's
called The Trevor Project Rogen's got
the pygmies
I got The Trevor Project when you sign
up for cash app use the promo code
Whitney not only will you instantly
receive $10 but the cash app will also
donate $10 to what The Trevor Project
mmm-hmm what does anything organization
that provides crisis intervention and
suicide prevention services to LGBTQ sad
mad about youth across America
[Laughter]
[Music]
first show the new year here we are I
have a lot IVA we have a lot of the
second show oh yes it is but this is the
first one we're really recording in the
new you know got it got it
happy new understood Happy New Year do
you caught off guard for the happiness
I'm really very happy me too I feel like
very rested I actually rested on the
break I cannot stand it when people come
back from a break exhausted I need a
vacation for my vacation
okay oh yeah that's gross it's your job
is to rest when you're not working yeah
and don't talk about your privilege yeah
I know exactly I just went skiing for
two weeks now I need to go to another
expensive place don't do activities on
your vacation and how about that how
about that how about that you know why
they gave so much energy I'm wearing a
minimizer bra and minim making your
heart beat faster your lungs are it's
like it's for a really tight sports bra
that makes you like it motions your
boobs down a lot but it also makes you
just kind of more your posture better it
make what you're saying is there's no
circulation every moment is my last look
here's my corset yeah people gonna ask
about it now it's like a giant band a
you guys can't see it it looks like um I
just flashed the YouTube thank you to
the YouTube channel check it out
subscribe it looks like a scuba suit it
looks like a scuba bra a scuba bra
goober bra and it is probably waterproof
certainly sweat proof remember when we
were on the road and I would wear those
shirts underneath with the what's the
sweat pocket yes so it's the same it's
the brand is called NYX KNI X they're
not a sponsor should be call me DM
Benton yeah we all sweat no but I love
their um because when I tour I wear
t-shirts that have like like sweat pads
i but yeah you know they have pads
yeah that's cuz I sweat too much it's
gross so I wear so much better than
sticking pads under your arms well I
used to do that I was just so maxi pads
into my blue shirts
yeah this whole thing let's get at it
it's like you know I
the Betsy Ross of perspiration huh ruts
of perforation second I was like Betsy
Ross what did she do again was she a
Kardashian also near near near Newark
making New Year I'm on your top eight is
my first daughter of 2020 I mean before
you gonna know that I need to know if
anybody got tickets to the tour oh no we
need to talk about the tour this is this
what I was about to say Oh new year new
me 2020 is that we excuse me stop
coughing sorry I had what am I posed to
do your what's in my throat
Benji a cop with a birthday cake
flavored protein drink and I'm sure your
throat now has cancer and it's Wow 20/20
not mess up my I'm blessed Holly if ever
that's not my vibe it's not you're gonna
throw cancer at me I noticed that I did
read some of the comments over the break
excited some time we were wrong a lot of
fake news on the show on the tour but
half the cities we announced we're not
even going there
why not one city also said we were go to
Miami Florida not going yeah but that's
because it is I've been there that's the
damn Miami Miami Miami Oklahoma called
Miami and I know that because I went
there into the show once and everyone
screamed princess at me while I was
onstage and it was a very trauma time
what did that mean I don't think it was
good but I want him over it worked out
well thin but yeah that's like of all
the hate crimes all the hate crimes
that's one of those flirtatious
compliment it's it's a it's Miami so we
were like going to Miami Florida send us
stuff to do in Florida and a bunch of
people were like I'm on your website I
don't see Miami and then where's your
North Carolina we talked about the
Carolinas I guess for but that I think
that way that's because on your original
like maybes yes and so then you're
confirm list I don't think we know how
the touring work then a people get
confuse I think you can just go wherever
you want but you can you can based off
of who you have to route it a certain
way
you know the idea when you do big tours
like this I mean we're doing about 25
cities I got the number wrong every time
you want to go Friday Saturday because a
lot of people can't go on a Wednesday or
Thursday and the Durham date that was
available was like a Wednesday and if
people are coming from far away you know
so Durham I think is gonna be work and I
think it's important to know when
they're always asking like what about
this why not this that you can always
add dates I'm gonna add date there could
be that's another part there's a lot of
options but also don't come at me in the
comments with like you said you were
coming to Detroit you're going to Royal
Oak that's the same area you know like I
know it's not Detroit Detroit it's right
outside world but don't because I kept
thinking that I was making way more
mistakes and I was making Connecticut
there was no clear water I think we said
st. Petersburg but they're very close to
each other there was a couple that with
a lot of fake news on the show we got to
pull it together in 2020 we because I
had all this shirt yes this is your job
you got to keep me in line you also need
to make sure I'm not so shiny
I'm Way too shiny I look this is two
different jobs I look insane on some of
these clips that I was like I look wet
that's a good look I look like I'm
slathered in KY jelly that's great for
Instagram people wanna be wet rich and
famous cable I poked the table this is
different I changed it for the new year
you guys I'm sorry
you hear this yes they say give us
trigger warnings when you make when you
hit the table and got it for a minute
here's your trigger warning don't listen
and they're happy so I also I'm gonna
work on being less shiny in the new year
that's another big thing for me I am
more shiny what's that no you're the
perfect like level of opalescent at the
moment obelus opalescent that's what I
would say you are there was also
something of when I decided to start the
podcast a big thing that I wanted to do
and why I called a good for you in the
first place is I wanted to be good for
you I wanted you to take away something
from the podcast be a better person like
that's what I love about podcast I love
learning stuff I like going away with
like a book or like a something like I
listen to Rogen a lot of Rogen over the
holiday the Sinclair one I was like
ordering vitamins I was like doing all
sorts of shit I was adding like tons of
zinc to cart' like I got all sorts of
stuff and I feel great so much you are a
good consumer you see it you you you
want it you know I want to hear things
from people I trust I want I
wanted to make a show that's good for
you and one thing that I always wanted
to do on the show was have like a word
of the week like a word of the pod we're
likely to talk about a new word because
a lot of people were saying in the
comments that they're like wouldn't you
use such big words which I never I don't
think of myself as doing that but maybe
I do and I think a part of it is well
first of all when I was in high school I
was so insecure about not being the
smartest person in the class like I was
never the smartest because I was held
back and I was always the youngest in my
class and so I feel like I worked extra
hard to try to be smart and I used to
like study the dictionary I used to read
the dictionary as a book and like write
words out and like write them in
sentences oh I can't really because I
remember when I'm it's not my thing
what was your thing I one time gave a
report and speech on why everyone should
love Paris Hilton I had a graph main
argument was my senior thesis for being
a high school yeah and what was they on
it I'll have you know and really yeah
okay it was just that you know she's
like cool well is that pretty much okay
good argument yeah I also had a chart
that explained to you it I mean if you
liked for yourself how much cooler you'd
be where what happened I just made the
chart up pretty much it was just like
and this will happen it was just a
minute pinion with an opinion class
pretty much and so oh god I got it okay
this wasn't a real no institution in
this class it was but it was like a
debate class so you had to debate like
that I like debating really impossible
arguments myung the whole point of it
let me give you the topic yeah I like
that
but everybody else would always juice me
I think a comedian is I think it's
taking an unpopular argument and then
defending it that's kind of what we get
what we do a lot like yeah playing
devil's advocate but I so I want to do a
word of the week just because I think we
talked a lot about communication on the
show we talked a lot about how to make
relationships better your employment
situation better your work situation
better and I think such a big part of
that is having effective clear concise
communication and I think that the
bigger your vocabulary is the better
your communication is gonna be because
you can like say what you actually mean
like and what's our word of the week we
have capricious wait we need like a
sound effect or something
capricious that's it will you define it
for us capricious capricious its
capricious capricious I push the butt
so it's that it's me on the phone it's
capricious capricious okay either
algorithm probably screwed it up it's
got some different capri-sun
given to sudden and unaccountable
changes of mood or behavior so
capricious almost the name of this
podcast capricious is basically if
somebody is unpredictable if someone is
hard to pin down and changes their minds
a lot right and it is in a pejorative
way like so a great drag queen name it's
a great stage capricious capricious odd
but it's a word that is used to describe
you know something that you can't really
pin down it's a synonym kind of to
mercurial I use mercurial which everyone
knows what mercurial is thank God
mercurial is like like mercury like on
per day you guys know when you're
mercury but also wild that's what this
word like sometimes mercs Merc well
mercurial would be more unpredictable
and you'd use that more to describe like
weather or something and it's less of a
judgment on it like the weather in San
Antonio is mercury my dream now is just
for a bunch of like girls at Starbucks
to be like I am so capricious like
honestly I think it's important to say
like this is an important word because
especially when you're like giving
advice to a friend or talking to a
friend about a relationship I think a
lot of times when our vocabulary is
limited we end up defaulting to
judgments so crazy it's just easy and
unhelpful and we just used the word like
a lot and you we used the word crazy and
psycho and that's not really what we're
trying to say you know we go to a great
point we have like crutch words so you
know I was talking to a friend of mine
on Year's Eve and she was talking about
this guy who you know he'd call Erlich
twice a day and they'd hang out like
four times a week and then he wouldn't
hear from me like she wouldn't hear from
him for like a week and then they'd have
a date and then the last minute he was
like I can't come tonight I'm going on a
canoeing trip or something you know that
a good word for that would have been man
I don't see gender so a no match of 2008
and then she's right you remember this
we were allowed to say that word without
there being a Marge
so the way that I explained I was like
it just seems like you're more
calculated structured person and he's
capricious who do you think calculator
is a positive or negative it's usually
pretty negative you just add it to her
anyways I did but I said like you're
more calculated like you she is she
didn't take it personally
she was fine with it like I don't think
calculate it has to be negative but I
think sometimes we inflate it with
manipulative you know or like conniving
and nefarious or diverse exactly what I
thought wants to like know her week in
advance yeah I guess calculated does
have a little bit of a negative
undertone but it was just hurt your
nature is somewhat rigid and structured
and his is capricious like YouTube
probably just aren't a good match and I
think that's when you want to use a word
like that instead being well he's just
probably like like he's just like crazy
yeah maybe just likes you too much I
don't know maybe he pushed you down you
guys are in love yeah so I think that
that's or especially when you're dealing
in like work situations when you have to
give constructive feedback I think it's
really important to have super specific
words so that it just stays very simple
you know like your behavior lately has
been capricious I need an explanation
and you're also good to confuse people
into doing what you want they don't know
and you know you can get a lot with a
lot they're just like because they don't
look dumb they're just like yeah
absolutely
where's my raisin we talked about it for
being very capricious no but a lot of
people want to talk about words on the
show so she says all that because we're
gonna try to work this word in for you
guys I think every every week we're
gonna have a new word if you want to
send us words because also we all know I
mean I'm sure most people know this word
they've heard it but I think sometimes
like words get out of the rotation and I
just want to bring words back into the
rotation sometimes because I find that
you know I'm talking to people
workwise and sometimes there's just like
a limited number of words you're
prepping for the SAT great podcast
Elizabeth
it also means like flaky you know like
she cancelled three times and decided to
go to Coachella instead she's yeah and
this is a serious but capricious it also
has like an innocent steward of like
she's just capricious see I disagree if
I really like a point I'm gonna use this
word if I don't be cute and be like oh
she's my friend she's flaky that's like
a key link yourself flaky but this is
negative bitch you're being capricious
and I'm done with it you are capricious
bitch
but capricious it has a little bit of
like that's just your nature instead of
like you're a flake
you're capricious that's just who you
are you're like I've been okay lady it
is what it is it is what it is
I'm 20/20 radical acceptance in people
radically I am in radical except that's
her mark I hung out with someone over
the break that is always late and she
was late and I was like you know what
that's who you are honestly it's my
fault at this point I should have
brought oh I'm so excited for 2020 2020
I'm in radical acceptance of everything
except this cake batter drink that you
just made me made you yeah I had such a
good break I did so many things that
were good for me Oh mutant up a storm
you love a good meal I was mutant all
over the place I am a mutant see we just
see on that I'm this is my 2020 thing
you've talked me into muting people
because I'm a real unfollow you bitch
like I want you to know that I did not
like something yeah you have it you're
not getting my follow-up I've had
someone someone we all know a big famous
person confront me about not following
him and it was traumatizing like a man
came up to me and was like did you
unfollow me and I was like no no no I
think it probably blamed to you I was
like Benton does my Instagram I don't
know great I kick like I am too
codependent to fully unfollow people oh
I have to out of obligation if my
friends if my friends if I haven't feel
like they've done me wrong I will
unfollow them and then follow them back
just so they know that I unfollowed them
you're a wild one that's sadistic but
now I'm over it sick person but I came
up with like a list of criteria just to
be very cut and dry about the people I
need unthaw because what I found was
everyone's complaining about how
unhealthy Instagram is and how toxic it
is I think it's toxic if you follow
people that bring out the worst in you
and make you judgmental and activate
your self-righteous indignation so I was
spending all the people I was following
I was why is he taking this many
pictures of oh my god why is she writing
that long of a caption like I was extra
Graham is training for life it's the one
place I need you guys if Benton hits the
table again I'm gonna have an actual
conniption I need does need to tap hold
your pants pants itself your pants to
yourself you guys bad dudes also no
wearing pants
if you get up grab on YouTube it's the
one place subscribe on yes oh my god my
thought Instagram is the one place that
prepares you for life where you can you
can cultivate who you want around ya you
can see only the things you yeah it's
like training for everything you're
still being like I'm very upset about
this yeah if you don't like what you're
sending about you your fault that's a
really good point you do not get to
control the people you meet in the world
you not get to control the people you
work with you do get to control the
people that are in your bed with you on
a screen literally you go to bed why
would you choose people that make you
feel bad comments you can't enjoy that
but the people who you're looking at you
get to can turn your comments off or you
can do that that's right you can't do
that Auto comment they forgot about
something you just have self-control and
not read them but I got savage about it
I got a pen and a piece of paper
remember those and I wrote out the
criteria for who I'm gonna mute me tail
anyone mute - no I did it - hashtag
mutant to mutant to use twenty20 we're
starting this as like number one if you
pose outside of a private jet oh let's
have my Instagram I cannot I unless
you're the rock he can do anything he
wants as far as I'm concerned she works
so hard I don't even care I'm muting
people uh-huh I'm using guys that have
their own name or their last name
tattooed on their back never seen that
in my life what yeah very popular you
following there's no you mean an athlete
with a jersey on no I mean like people
to have their little names or lasted
this is you've never seen it I've never
seen never coming kind of okay now
you're follow monsters no I mean I don't
follow that horrible of people I will
unfollow you if you post quotes about
self-help and motivational life advice
that you yourself do not take oh that
was in mind - really people who every
post is an inspiration to post inspire
me well it's a long something to be said
for that but my thing is don't post
instagrams they're like sometimes the
best way to communicate is to not say
anything at all but all you do is run
your goddamn mouth or the people home
whoa I disagree if your Instagram post
is that long in that metaphor write a
book I don't I don't want to hear it
every time oh that's interesting
I'm just talking about the little
squares that have one quote in them and
they think they're like drop mic
dropping something
super profound like someone who's like
the only way to win is to not play I'm
like well why are you jumping into every
spout on Twitter like it least you love
playing at least have your behavior and
your advice be Congress that's all I ask
be conquered this is this Congress what
I rested over the branch yeah my brain
is only had one word of the day and it's
getting we're getting off to a rough
people who in their Instagram caption
talked about how they're taking a break
from social media Oh God like hey guys
it's like I've been taking a break from
social media to like live IRL I didn't
notice I didn't know you were gone I'm
also following nine hundred other people
no one met some of them are on private
jets I didn't notice you weren't here
and also why are you bragging about how
you're not on social meet you're not
better than me yelling that to or when
someone's like hey I know everyone wants
me to post more I know everyone's really
wanted to know where I got this top
target Oh we'll get bats
what do you think that that's real when
people I think that cyber you asking me
what foundation I use so I'm fine I'll
make a video I think that is true for
some people I think there are some
people who definitely have the followers
that truly do want to know things I do
believe that but I think that there are
people who mystify their life and
they're like I'm like I know that that
many people are not asking you because I
can really see the number of people fall
I know they're not asked but also don't
be shameless and pretend just be
shameless be authentic no guys I'm gonna
do a video about my makeup routine don't
be like everyone you guys are like
begging yeah or just say like hey I
really like this and I want to share it
yeah I love this shirt I got guess where
it's from Target don't act like we don't
like our Jo humming phone muting are we
now allowed to do target I don't like
that I just didn't know I could leave on
it you know maybe people would a brag
like I love that when people brag about
how little they've spend on something
when you're like I like that type of
like $12 tarjay yeah okay like that's
what normal people spend on their
clothes yeah I don't want you to tell me
the price of anything good or bad I
don't care that's like when people want
to brag about how to get every
Zaara like I love Zara but that sure is
ARRA $40.00 and you're like $40 is like
what clothes should cost
why are you bragging that you made a
good choice are you bragging that you
finally made a financial so that was a
compliment say thank you yeah just say
thank you don't tell me how much you're
sure cause this is so tacky yes they say
anything else you could never oh this is
another thing I have to mute people if
they try to trick their followers into
commenting below look we all know by now
everyone is savvy enough to know that if
you comment the more comments you get
the more likely you are to get an
algorithm more likely you are to get
into the main feed so I feel like now so
you're muting people for good business
practices well it's just I don't like it
when it's so disingenuous like when
someone's like like a celebrity is like
eating ice cream and like what's your
favorite ice cream flavor comment below
and everyone's like then it's like
sponsored by cold you care yeah hashtag
ad like Breyers like you don't care like
I don't know maybe it just seems a
little bit transparent to me and maybe
I'm also by the way trying to not put my
chin up so high for those of you
watching on YouTube I basically look at
the sizzling during this podcast and
it's all nostril so I'm trying to keep
my chin down everyone I just want to
tell you about but I that just bothers
me because it feels just so fake I mean
it definitely I do it sometimes I do it
I do it when I'm like tell me what city
to come to you mean what guest you want
but I actually really not saying it's
healthy but I actually read the comments
if I do it if I'm bored I respond to
commands yeah I respond to people's
comments too yeah a lot you know but I
don't think the average like celebrity
with 50 million followers is like
checking their fans ice cream flavors no
they're working they're very bitter very
bitter use on their back that's a thing
looking up never I am
muting anyone who posts in their caption
that them and their friends in a reality
show what here's my I'm more looking to
people I'm gonna find people follow them
in people that are worse than the people
I follow because I think you're you're
talking about your actual friends I'm on
a hunt to find people to mute a popular
page and be like commuting you just
wanna roast people say you've never even
ever seen
you've never seen a caption that's like
oh my god me and my friend we need we
have to have reality show we should
definitely have one and then every
comments all the other group of friends
like we must we have to yeah but you
have one it's your Instagram everyone
has their own reality show now that's a
great point yes I don't think anyone
thought about it but my point is that if
you don't you don't need one yeah this
wasn't fun at all yeah like whatever you
but this is not good but it's also kind
of funny because it is pejorative like
having a reality show normally that is a
negative thing like a bunch of people
being shameless and tacky and trashy so
the idea that the best you think you can
do is a reality show that people love to
hate is such a weird like in your
narcissism you are also kind of real I
like revealing how low yourself is
Neiman yeah you're like we're so good at
drinking and eating salads like you
should get you know - yeah oh that
everyone like kind of hates and makes
fun of I'm all about heel being like
confident but I'm like it's not good I'd
be a good show yeah no I know I've heard
of that I think I've definitely I mean
I'm in Hollywood that's all anybody ever
said no I think I've heard of it I like
that answer but uh another thing I'm
gonna mute people is if they in their
Instagram story document an entire
concert oh there there what in what way
in what world that's not follow from
Amman following it am I gonna watch you
hold your I'm looking at a black hole
first of all from your nosebleed seats
and then I'm just looking at little dots
of other people they were filming the
concert doing the same exact thing I
need a mute that all everyone in there
like if I want to see Beyonce perform
I'm not gonna watch it from your
Instagram story with your Chad toobut
yeah go on YouTube where there was a
cinematographer who actually knows how
to put something into focus like your
cinematography stinks that is pure that
is 100% like look at this fun thing I'm
doing it's my fun thing I'm getting to
do finally and I need everyone to know
that I do fun things I'm not jealous cuz
you're just filming it the whole time to
make me jealous I know I might rather
you just take a cute picture by the
entrance and that's on you that's it or
like the ticket I like people just post
like the ticket at a meet-and-greet
that's cool maybe but to document the
entire thing shittily is I have Spotify
I see people I see people on sometimes
that will do like usually it's like The
Bachelor
shows like that well they will document
the entire show on their Instagram story
and then I why would i watch that's are
they doing commentary kind of I do like
that really I mean yeah I like that
occasionally I think if you're if you're
funny and you're doing funny commentary
that's like live-tweeting Club why would
I choose to watch a show in your show
because Instagram if I like if I like
you yeah I did
I liked you big fan and you're like guys
I'm gonna live-tweet this show that we
all like together I'm like oh my god I'm
watching you instagrams live Instagram
whatever like I'm doing it with you it's
here what's going I mean David Spade
doesn't it's funny when he does that
Leslie Jones does it with the Olympic
game of Thrones when she shoot Game of
Thrones all right you're right I guess
if you know what if you guys are back
we're you're followed your follow
unmuted I think if I guess if you're if
you're good at it I want but if you're
trash that's yeah just that's it ramune
you made it's trash that's that that's
the topic here I'm muting anyone that
confuses weather and climate I'm done
with it thank you not here any more
rants about it I can you explain the
difference you've put the people in this
room that don't know you've never seen
someone be like I don't understand
global warming it's raining right now
I'm like that's whether that's whether
that's not the climate okay god I gotta
got it it's from the person who argued
very cool yeah I know things around it
that's a key be well-rounded 2020 I
don't like when people say cement what
cement versus cement I don't like that
either
hey when they caught semen yeah but I
can't stand there and guys like
everyone's constantly giving me a speech
about that on some platform really and
they always have a picture of like
follow this is wild I've never heard of
any of these things I definitely am
gonna mute you if you just Amiga you I'm
just gonna benjin that's another person
people they go on and on about how bad
their anxiety is on Instagram like ah I
don't know how bad your anxiety is if
you post about it four times a day
surely you're not that anxious about
what people think about you again write
a book you might need a little more
anxiety too much now we're just you need
more anxiety that's my that's my tag for
all 2020 no you need more anxiety
honestly you're - you're too healthy I
know everyone's I just really want to be
fearless this year I'm like you're
pretty fearless with the amount of posts
that you sent it so embarrassing that
every year people are like I want to cut
toxic people I want to be fairly
personal I think we need to all agree on
a definition of toxic if someone doesn't
agree well you know people are mixing
this up people I just made a phase and I
was speaking aid vention laughs no I
that was me disagree I know that with
what you were saying I do not a lot of
people I need to cut out these toxic
people and it's like pundits that just
don't agree with them like if someone
doesn't agree with you that doesn't make
them toxic that just makes them someone
with a different opinion yeah which you
know maybe let's talk to you oh you
don't like it no that's not toxic that
are smart but happen to disagree with
you toxic but your tires mine you can't
handle someone having a valid I agree
agreeing thanks but here's my thing if
you're so dumb that that do you don't
like that then maybe they're toxic to
you I just rather you just I'd rather
you ignorant says talks I'd rather you
cut them out then constantly argue or be
obsessed about but you're the toxic
person if you keep needing to argue with
someone who's smarter than you on yeah
but you can't cut you out you got to
live with you I can't cut me open
I can't cut me out the white meat okay
okay also where do we land on and Dave
you should chime in on this too because
I'm curious what about putting your
tweets on Instagram does that annoy you
Benton does not know you I do it so but
is it only ones that you're like this
one hit
it's ones that I laugh at myself and I
just want people be like I also have I
also have a Twitter
so the my twitter has less followers in
my stream so I'm like can you name all
from come over here that's my mom I just
feel like Instagram is a visual medium
and it's like I'm watching TV and
someone's giving me like a book to read
and I'm like that's not when I sign
for here we're doing here you know
especially when it's like all of a
sudden like political or something it's
like whoa no no I don't do anything
political yeah no I just mean like
sometimes people will like repost one of
their tweets under their Instagram and
sometimes jarring to me this is why I'm
also muting people who take naked photos
and call it art some of it is yeah agree
but if you're um if we're just in a
jockstrap bout waterfall I'm muting you
what are they calling it art are they
doing like yes Dan when someone is like
this is my stuck short just took freedom
I'm pressing I'm like no you're naked in
a park you're naked in a park and it's
not you're just showing your whole two
squirrels and I don't like it or holes
I set holes they said hole no no grow a
hole is gross holes that's nice so
that's a lot of muting to do I must have
muted 80 people I would say I'm muted at
least 80 people I feel lighter I feel
better I like them more and I also would
say like I'm doing this for us
I want you to know that I am I like you
more when you're muted yeah and I
followed and muted about 80 people so
really I mean I meant looking something
else I want to do new year new me 2008
um I do want to do less cutting in the
show which is part of the reason I'm
talking so slowly I'm trying to avoid
cuts in the future and I do think a lot
of people noticed that we made a big cut
in the Ronan Farrow interview a couple
weeks ago yes we did correct
we had to wasn't Ronan's fault he didn't
ask for it but I did go on a diatribe
about Woody Allen that would have like
gotten Ronan's Pulitzer Prize revokes
for even being in the same room with me
because Ronan is a brilliant objective
journalist and he is so fair and he is
so um biased and I went on a rant about
what he Allen so we did cut some of that
out some of it was lovely yeah and also
like that's how it works so twenty20 get
over it
2028 radical acceptance but no I just I
really I mean I think I said a little
bit of it but I feel like I was putting
on a tough spot because I truly think
that Woody Allen is overrated like I
think it's wild that we're all just like
pretending then he's just like mad you
don't relate to the women in those
movies dude why are all the women all
the women in all of his movies are
rgeous and they're in like olive cargo
shorts why they're in peasant tops like
I I love American Eagle as much as the
next person but I don't understand why
every woman has to be dressed like that
and also they're all just like rich for
no reason they're all like in grad
school like in threesomes like what in
what world and they're all this drives
me nuts like some like modern women oh
all of his female characters are like so
self-absorbed so selfish so capricious
so capris and they I just I feel like
they're made for a very small group of
like Upper Eastside therapists yeah or
something it's a it's a reflection of
there was a lot of stuttering yeah it
was a reflection of a very small poll of
women yeah I just feel like we're all
Annie Hall was very good but I I mean I
think Diane Keaton is an effervescent
delight and I think such and I think
everyone's like trying to bank that his
next movie will be Annie Hall again the
next movie Annie Hall again it's just
not happening they're fine to watch on
planes but I don't think they're worth
putting up with his nonsense
I think he's for creep tell me why do
you want to hit wonder why do you have
to marry your wife's foster kid it's not
we were too young for I don't really
remember this I don't know that's why do
you do we I was too young to understand
what's going on okay Woody Allen is
married to this okay like what's the big
deal and now as an adult looking back
like you're a famous director you could
marry anyone why do you have to marry
your foster kid wild iyo G behind that
huh I don't like to know the psychology
behind that like why'd that's who year I
mean I guess they would just say like
some sick power thing and I think people
give him a pass cos he's short
I think short guys have had a to go down
too long they get angry quick yeah but
Napoleon yeah Napoleon miles Manson was
5 - yeah but singing where's the study
on that he did and then and then that
movie with Meryl Hemingway like the I
think was called Manhattan she was 16
and he was like 40-something and they
kissed on screen and he like went to her
house and like ask the parents to like
take like there was lots of creepy
they're just creepy shit and I'm bi I'm
good
yeah that's muta Bermudian creepy shit
and I also I also feel like his move
like it's always just like hot women
making out in Europe like who's this
movie for me I bet you liked his movies
I'm surprised no I mean I don't really
care about them at all to be honest with
you no I never thought about a day in my
life till I came in this room really no
shit
also what if you're making movies in
2020 without explosions get the fuck out
of here yeah this podcast is gonna blow
up in what world like this is a play why
did you have to bring cameras into this
I did a lot of other things over the
break I watched TV never get to do
that's shocking I watched all of mine
hunter I also watch mine honey melon or
Steve Jobs I was gonna tell anybody but
I did she did I got many a minion
message that said did you watch mine
hunter yet and I said I'm working on it
just are you done yeah I watched the
entire two seasons and look it's because
everyone's I mean everyone people love
it I know we'll D'Elia it's his favorite
show and I was like fine I'll watch it
it's look it's brilliant Adventure is
amazing brilliant amazing show he's for
those of you who don't know who David
Fincher is I mean Fight Club seven gone
girl which I still am fighting with him
in my head about gone girl what's that I
even though I saw an interview where he
said that he wanted couples to leave
gone girl and fight in the car
which I loved like he likes to provoke
in his in his work so I like I see what
he's doing in mine hunter but it's it's
impeccably done the first season people
say is slow I don't I think everything
is so specific and mindful and
everything everything he does is on
purpose so I just like I forgive the
fact that it's a little the pacing is a
little bit slow I noticed that I do feel
like I found myself getting annoyed and
this isn't David Fincher's thing this is
what happened I just feel like whenever
there's something about a serial killer
it every serial killer it just feels
like it's always the mom's fault true
ever not only not only the mom but then
it just trickles down into women it's
always the moms fault it's a world of
shit just like being a better mom or
been around more loved Tim Moore maybe
he would stop hacking women up in the
woods like I don't know she would have
told him he was a little huh I don't
even
I don't think any amount of good
parenting is gonna stop a psychopath if
someone's gonna do I just like I know
its nature and nurture and we know what
we say and I'm Alan on is that genetics
loads the gun environment pulls the
trigger right so it's a little bit of
both whoa whoa what that was bold why I
never heard that mm-hmm and now I know
it and it's so different
yes that's the idea hi guys good for you
you can leave it knowing more I'm not to
use that on people brag to your friends
and I just it just okay imagine being if
today I said I'm gonna be an uber driver
and a post mate and a cleaning lady and
a chef I'd say what happened that's well
you would say that's too many jobs that
was every mom in the 50s had that many
jobs and they were expected like make
eye contact with their kids all day like
what in what world but it's also like
every person in mine hunter every killer
that they talk to it's like but I felt
embarrassed okay what I was embarrassed
okay so you're welcome to my okay yes I
think they're like this this woman
embarrassed me look put aren't women
embarrassed by everything all the time
we live in a constant state of
embarrassed I mean I'm gonna really like
like you're like gene you can't punch up
like it is true we are constantly that's
why we have such big purses we are
hiding things in our purse that we're
embarrassed about it all I'm always
embarrassed all of the time we're made
to feel embarrassed about our face about
our legs if they have any hair on it
about our armpits about our mustaches
those of us who have them yeah our chin
hairs we all have those right our uni
brows like at were managing about
everything all the time and we're not
out hacking pending all these men and
this show are just like well she said I
had a unibrow I didn't want to sleep
with me that hurt my feel and I just
started I start like chopping people up
in the woods yeah and they're just like
isn't that crazy how his mom didn't love
him and you're like no no you didn't
listen the whole story but it's also by
the way there was a guy that was like
wearing pantyhose and like masturbating
with pantyhose and she was like stop
doing that it's like okay like well you
can't masturbate in the house right she
didn't have that she didn't have what we
have now which is tumblr to tell us what
that meant yeah yeah but it's also like
you can't run around jerking off in the
house with or without a panty hose it's
like the pause felt bad pity boys aren't
even the problem here do it
your room like to me there's a fine line
between shaming and parenting right give
him a lock yeah you have to you can't
have come all over your living room it's
crazy and you you probably do but you
can't like he comes running out like
she's just told me I wasn't allowed to
masturbate in my fishnet hose in the
middle of the living room like of course
you're not don't be an animal also I
freaking out why he was in the living
room I don't know and then she shamed me
for doing some like all right like we
all need a little shame so that we can
function and also like you've obviously
come to terms with wanting to wear
pantyhose in touch yourself she has had
no time to process those her initial
reaction to that like you have to give
her a little bit of time you kind of
think I'm gonna kill something it's a
lot to process with a goldfish even if
you're not phobic it's a lot to take in
it's just a shot it is a shot but hoping
you'd be like what the hell are you
doing you can't internalize everyone's
reaction all the time you just gotta go
like let me circle back let me give you
a second to work through that honey you
can just go around snapping necks cuz
somebody caught you with your hoo-ha out
right but also psychopathy is genetic I
might hop a--they we all you guys know
this right yes I copy these genetic
being a psychopath is a lack of empathy
it's a wiring issue so a lot of that is
just genetic it has nothing to do with
how much you got breastfed or loved or
if your mom mashed up your peas or
whatever everyone expects moms to do for
their kid and so it is genetic so the
moms also could have been Psychopaths
and they pulled it together
yeah good for them yeah bad stuff to do
you think they don't want to go kill
people in the woods they play when to
come home more than you could they do
with your weird pushed it down like
adults they handled it you think your
mom didn't see you in pantyhose and one
to break some neck what do you mean she
got a spine she swallowed it had a glass
of rose a and moved on my because I look
like I understand the anger this was
because I guess it took place in the 70s
like late seventies so these would have
been happening in the 50s I mean the 50s
was a nightmare and the only reason the
women got all the blame is cuz the guys
weren't around you know they were at the
discotheque or the disco they're at the
disco so if the guys with them if the
fathers were around I'm sure they would
have fucked him up just as much as the
moms had to be home oh yeah
my parents in the 50s everyone dropped
the ball the generation before that were
in factories working kids used to work
in factories and I feel getting shamed
by your mom for jerking off in pantyhose
is a step up from the generation before
we're all just doing the best we can so
don't you like you were embarrassed a
lot at the child cuz I do I thought I
was embarrassed all the time constantly
well I think I truly think that that is
part of the reason why people become
comedians I'll speak for myself as
you're trying to control the way you get
embarrassed Oh 100 I can say something
about me and I'm like I was in control
of that if you cinema cow dearie what
I'm gonna make fun of myself before you
do yeah comedy is my go to do I'm gonna
control how I made fun of and I'm gonna
do it myself I mean was I embarrassed as
a kid my last name is Cummings fuck
outta here yeah people should call me
Benton gay which is not clever so Alec
it is it's a very I mean my last name is
coming so I had a pretty R but also like
I just had an embarrassing like like I
used to get driven to school in a pickup
truck with like dogs in the back and
like the dogs would jump out I now
understand that that was cool but it was
so embarrassing at the time you know it
embarrass me you telling the story I
don't think it's cool now right okay oh
and I remember my aunts were always go
with builds character it's builds
character that's always what they would
say and I would make them drop me off
like four blocks from the school and
then I would get out and all the dogs
would follow me and then they'd have to
like call the dogs they'd be like good
it would be yelling and all the kids
were just like what a nightmare it
really embarrass myself more than my
parents embarrass me
I would like show up in school like I
would wear a Halloween costume that has
an outfit like well into the 8th grade
that tracks not like not a full costume
but like because I was very gods like
yeah I'd wear like a cape just a just a
full Dracula cape but it was cool to me
thank you it was a grim reaper cloak and
I got this on top yeah we did it I am I
had braces as a kid I also had really
bad acne as again edge of leg braces on
my mouth but I had the clear braces
because I thought it would be less
embarrassing than the metal one but the
clear ones aren't clear they're whatever
color food you just ate yeah you're just
having yellow teeth all the time and
they did it takes so much longer for
those to work so I had them on for like
four years and like we couldn't afford
to get them fixed so they were always
like the rubber
hands were always like I had the ones
with the rubber bands that like moved
when you talked the colored I never had
braces oh you're very straight teeth
thank you you're welcome
I never had braces I watched a lot of
dramas over the break that had look
American actresses just aren't working
anymore we're hiring English actresses
Australian actresses Irish actresses I'm
not mad at it they're all very talented
I'm not complaining gorgeous gorgeous
skin the skin because they're not in the
freaking Sun doesn't happen that's right
the English people are not in tanning
beds getting melanoma at 14 the way we
are and but I did notice though like I'm
always trying to figure out like what's
the impact of like all this stuff that's
happening in Hollywood with like
harassment and all this stuff and I a
lot of the actresses not from America
they're American accents or a little
walk walk
yes and you I didn't notice until you
said it wouldn't have a very acute sense
of hearing mm-hmm but she hears things
that the average human does not so
mental illness but he no I was watching
one that was um I'm not gonna tie the
name of it but it was the actress was
like would you like to go down to the
link should we go to the link then maybe
we should go for a ride in the cart and
they didn't turn you on you sell like a
broken robot like all these girls sound
like German assassins or something like
would you like to UM go inside with me
someone evil trying to for be nice do
you I'm not gonna get you but it's these
are all brilliant actresses that could
easily get the accident right I just I'm
convinced that everyone is so scared to
give a female actress a note because
they're afraid they're gonna get sued or
something so they go that's right that's
great but it's always in the are that
you can tell because that's the
difference between the English accent
and an American accent is the are right
yeah Bart thought so uh girls are
hitting ours like real hard they're like
would you like to UM take me for a ride
into a race car yours like what what's
happening someone just tell her sounds
crazy she's like what a comfortable
cabinet totally they all sound like Siri
they're just enunciated on there really
that's a hardened unsee you can tell the
non-american actresses because they
actually speak proper English whereas
Roger like sloppy and they're barely
talk y'all sound really well-spoken
that's like what does she do I know I'm
like is this supposed to be from the 40s
like I'm not I wasn't sure like I
watched a couple of them I was like what
does this take place
we thought she was like so you need help
see ya you see we're going down to the
lake kissing but I truly think that it's
because everyone's afraid to give
actresses notes at this point there's
like I'm gonna get sued I don't know but
like they can do it these are brilliant
actresses just tell them they want to
get it right they don't want to sound
crazy how would you give the note you
would just say like hey so um just give
the note so the directors can just play
this back home yes I'm sure David
Fincher's listen woman to woman yeah you
would just say like hey you can soften
up that are it's a little hard it feels
a little formal which is a little firm
or just let them listen back to it got
it got it so no no hard like you sound
terrible bitch never talk to someone
like that I mean that's how I thought
Hollywood worked yeah you just well
usually there's an accent coach on set
or something like that but it's just
like someone there's just like oh the R
is a little hard you can be a little
softer or more conversational more
prosaic with it and they'll go great and
they can do it these are all actresses
that can do it it's just no one's
telling them be more prilosec when it
comes with gosh stop making her audience
stupid or I'm trying to make them
smarter and I just want to balance and
make up odd cast that's good for
acceptance that's me as a ik means
conversational and he just turned into
prilosec who does not sponsor this
podcast so we're not this sure though
did I need it I don't even know what it
is
that's a refund for hackers oh my gosh
you think this is another thing and we
have to get to busy soon I was watching
a couple shows that I feel like we're
clowning on Los Angeles in a way that
made me really annoy like I watched a
couple shows that portrayed people in
Los Angeles as like these like girls
named Amber who like just have flowy
dresses and our barefoot and they don't
wear bras and none of them eat gluten
and like they're always meditating it's
that is not how la people are that's
they're not like that at all it is such
a played-out stereotype and I'm the
first person to clown on LA trust me but
this is not a everyone in LA is like
hardcore like up at 5:00 a.m. like doing
Crossfit like half three businesses like
everyone's trying to be your Joe Rogan
yeah that's a very small group of LA but
you can find those people anywhere yeah
yeah true but we're in they good at from
but it's also by the way the idea that
people in LA are dumb is just like the
Jet Propulsion Laboratory from NASA is
here like
Mars rover is in Pasadena 20 miles away
I don't think people are dumb at all I
mean I've been here half a year now and
I look like anyone's dumb or a
stereotype in LA more just regular
average show people have like implants
or injections that any rehearsing on
yeah that's probably like I mean just
people you're like that just a Panda
Express why you look like that's like
very like I'm like mean good for you
like is a bitch it's great that's
available yeah your joy but I mean when
you go around LA I mean there truly are
like Botox places like they're like
Starbucks there's so much they're not
even like dermatologist they're just
like in and out like a drive-through one
sign of the day that said teeth
whitening forever one-time payment and I
was like that seems wrong no don't do
that you want to do a couple payments
you don't want a one-time thing doesn't
seem good I'm good yeah there is I mean
it's interesting we were talking about
this the other day because I actually
don't have Botox in my forehead but I
walked into a shelf remember that yeah
and I read of one of your wrinkles so I
have like an accidental wrinkle removal
do you see this Davis looks like crazy
no he said that the tissue it broke the
muscle or something so it looks like I
got like weird bad luck at least I would
have done the whole thing I have no
judgments about that but I do think that
yes you're right that that is a fine
line color that is it Ferris every night
I think in LA people are just like
generally shinier yeah in LA I think a
lot of women do I think what actually
makes it look Chinese is the laser and
it takes off the hair on your face and
that's why you look like lizardy yeah
it's always a new skin yeah but I mean
my experience really if people are very
nice uh-huh
that hope everybody's fake I haven't
experienced that I think that if that's
your fault if you're around with all the
fake people that's right and by the way
no one wears skirts everyone's in
sweatpants everyone said like overpriced
Lululemon is so true sweatpants city I
mean yeah everyone's in sweatpants and
like maybe like miniskirts and Uggs like
that tracks but no one's in long flowy
skirts there's no no ones like
everyone's like embarrassed to be too
gendered here like no one wants to wear
skirts it I mean it also like they want
to like keep the door open for being
binary I think that people have that's a
big misconception a lot of LA is
misconceived
yes concur you mean the people that are
actually born here
how dare they at least great it's
beautiful everywhere you look as beauty
it doesn't matter I don't know it's like
this is no I'm not trying to talk about
LA I just I found that like I watched a
couple shows where that was a go to and
I think the thing that that was the most
nettlesome about it was that they were
clowning on people that try to be
healthy you know like oh you're gonna
like you and you're gluten-free agave
nectar it's like people are trying to
not get cancer like not everybody who
eats healthy is a narcissistic tool like
a lot of people first of all gluten-free
like celiac that's a real thing like I
used to I used to make fun of
gluten-free people a lot and I also
stopped eating so much gluten I feel so
much better also but I think clowning on
people that are trying to take care of
themselves it's just lame like oh look
at you trying to not get care that's
true but on the flip side people are
also like oh you know always clowning on
like butter and deep-fried things if
everybody does that's an idiot that's
true yeah I guess everybody is very
unhealthy but you're not dumb yeah I
think that I think that people clown on
people who are just like trying like I
ate trash my entire life I'm just trying
to like reverse the damage isn't it
funny both those people are considered
dumb if you're super healthy bad you're
everyone but yeah I do think though it's
also just like it's people assume that
if people take care of themselves or eat
healthy or whatever it's like elitist so
it's like no like people in my family
take care of themselves and have to eat
like that because like they don't have
health insurance and it's way more
expensive to eat shitty than it is to
eat healthy food is medicine in the long
run oh you are LA for sure yeah I think
there are super smart great people in LA
they're just not out of the closet in
their home ok so our guest today is one
of my favorite people in the planets we
did this interview actually a couple
weeks ago and it's coming up now for a
litany of reasons
her name is busy Phillips you know her
busy I don't I don't know there's
nothing to say I mean I just need to let
you guys hear the interview because you
know her and I don't want to sound like
super anxious because she is a good
friend of mine and I love her
and it's been so exciting to see her get
this new level of success just with her
being her she's my spirit animal but you
can't say that no you can't say anywhere
that word is canceled from what I gather
but I love her
according to Rihanna we do whatever she
says ya know Rihanna
someone called Rihanna out for using the
word spirit animal and she goes got it
like understood like she didn't get
defensive about did she say God I wish
mean like bitch I got a fuking Rihanna
don't know what this up tags was but
busy um actually she was in the news
this week because she posted about how
the show ended and I just want people to
know that had we been doing the
interview today I would have asked her
about it yes cuz that letter nope she
posted the like sardine grab of the text
exchange with head of the network
look I've been counseled by II I've been
through this I know exactly what that
feels like but um but busy like she's
just exactly who she is I love talking
to her because I think a lot of times
especially on her podcast people feel
this pressure to agree and to get along
and busy if you say something she was
like yeah but I'm not like that like she
knows exactly who she is performing for
you know she knows exactly who she is
she doesn't agree just for the sake of
agreeing she doesn't say she likes
something she doesn't like like she's
just like it's actually just really
refreshing and a great reminder to just
be like radically yourself at all times
and shit will work out that a fair thing
to say
she's radically busy she's radically
busy she's she's this is what I like to
call busy and I don't say this about a
lot of people she's a true original she
nobody like her she's a true original
she's just she's just a little
perfection wrapped up in an evening and
you know because so many people like you
have you noticed like you'll have a
friends who like you know them and then
you see them around a different group of
people and they're totally different
person who's that
you know people that just shape-shift to
try to get approval of everybody or
they're a different person on social
media than they are in person than their
artwork
Bizzy is who she is and it's working out
pretty well yeah it's working out real
well Busy Philipps
she's years buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
buh buh buh buh
[Applause]
you better help me you better help me
since your needs and match you with your
own licensed professional therapist you
can start your communicating under 24
hours I have control is not a crisis
line it's not special counseling done
securely online there's a broad range of
experts and better help counseling
expertise and experts and better helps
counselor network which may not be
locally available in many areas services
available to clients worldwide it's
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and FRA to change counselors if needed
fraud means fresh free your life today
visit their website and read their
testimonials that are posted daily visit
better help calm slash Whitney it's
better help h e LP and join over 500,000
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional that was my lines we're
good for you listeners get Whitney stop
slash swing Roman all right I wish I
wish I wasn't so familiar with why this
product exists most guys have tried
different ways to last longer but saying
the Pledge of Allegiance in your head or
counting backwards from ten doesn't
always work that's it brag when you said
that what I wish I didn't need people
didn't think you were bragging I get
this product the folks at Roman it's a
men's health company they've changed the
game with Roman swipes the secret to
longer lasting sexuals Roman swipes are
clinically proven that with ways to less
easy to use and fast-acting a
prescription coz that's embarrassing
Roman can ship swipes to you in a
discreet unmarked package each swipes
packet is small enough to hide in your
wallet a man with the wallet I already
like this for whatever you need it
swipes are great they won't transfer to
your partner so you can last longer
during the sexuals without worrying
they're super easy to use you just take
a swipe out of the packet you can swipe
it on your
and then you let it dry and you're good
to go that's a little too hard that's
kind of what it says $10 off your first
order and free two-day shipping and get
Roman comm / Whitney that's me get Roman
comm / Whitney for $10 off and free
two-day shipping you'll thank me later
ladies
you're welcome Roman comm / Whitney get
it get it
swipe it I don't know but can you are we
rolling
look at my headphones is that make it
what is that why is it dirty that's my
makeup that's the caulk I put on my face
encrusted it looks like chowder on my
headphones
this is fully disgusting we need to like
disinfect my headphones hey bro I had to
borrow my daughter's water bottle today
so I really look like a visco girl but
um I lost my favorite Hydra flask
yesterday post therapy I don't know I
don't understand I got in my car I'm
getting codependent about your earrings
in these I'm gonna you know but you
don't have to use that I love a
headphones and I know I just know
everything makes me feel safe and it
feels great Amaury I love it we have
really good oh look at we have a head
wave ASMR head nice and we're gonna do a
little ASMR anything if I have creation
smoothie MIT of I'm sorry that's why I
take care earrings Oh mm-hmm do you
listen ASMR no but birdy likes like you
used to like some of that like watching
the videos yeah she liked ones that
would gross me out though like um like
popping slime yeah you know like yeah
like that kind of ASMR which is not my
favorite thing that disgusting anything
that feels like it's a banana in
someone's mouth and that stuff makes me
really physically curses me out I do
like the tearing though for some reason
do tear stuff yeah because that like
nails on the chalk yeah I don't like
yeah mmm no I don't get like I don't
know sounds are not the thing that
called me
what comes again like like being
immersed in water oh really
have you done the floatation tank yes I
have I really like it really yeah
I wanna Pasadena oh my I've only been in
New York okay
so place the most stressful place on the
planet the idea that they have flotation
take in the middle of the city is so
funny to me yeah but I feel like oh well
right but you got you go in you take an
hour mm-hmm float come out I don't do a
total darkness though because I have
claustrophobia so that would be a
nightmare I had a panic attack and one
in Utah was it dark and I got up and
tried to get out and they're like man
I've been here for half an hour they're
like it's been two minutes and I was
like sorry you do have to kind of like
you meditate you meditate I tried yeah
but I don't do I tried to do the David
Lynch thing em yes the magis some guy
just texted me that from two friends
from Steve Agee and my friend Kujira
uh-huh he's like they both have said you
need me clothes I've never done it
closing your eyes for 20 minutes is Amir
we'll work miracles because the amount
of stimulus that we take in you know
even just closing your eyes is a big
deal because it stops our brain from
having to process all the things that
we're seeing but I actually work with
his attachment strategy guy and we do
the meditations forgiveness meditations
that actually really help me and I don't
do them at the same time every day but
if I'm like you know have five minutes
here five minutes I'll close my eyes and
the mantra is I forgive you you forgive
me I forgive myself I don't and you just
say it over and over again I forgive you
you forgive me I forgive myself
mm-hmm okay I can do that yeah it's just
so because I can't think about nothing
when people just think about nothing I
know I don't know what that means my
inner monologue is just a child
screaming mmm well I have actual
children's for me about triggering I
feel like you and I pretty much only see
each other on camera these days we hang
out as long as there's microphones and
cameras around is the only time we get
to see each other that's true but it's
also like just uh I feel like at this
point I don't know this is just the life
the lives we lead like we both work so
much and we have a bunch of other things
that are important to us
yeah outside of the things that we do
for money the amount of podcast and
stuff that I do when I'm hang out with a
friend of mine who's comedian and we're
just talking I'm like we're them
you're doing no one this huh we do I
mean we're just gonna talk without
cameras because some of the guys cover
this who's this ASMR listen up this is
actually a big deal that year round cuz
I think you might be one of the only
people that knows how weird I am I know
everything you like he knows more about
me than pretty much anyone it was funny
I you texted me my god when did I fly
back from New York last night the night
before Hey
and you texted me right after I had
finished talking about you with the
flight attendant I didn't use her name
but there was some wild shit going on on
my flights by flight to New York and my
flight back and so then the flight
attendant came over was talking to me
about like the I was said oh what's the
wildest thing that's ever happened on a
flight that you've been on and he said
oh well I used to do the Europe flights
and that's when people get really crazy
because of the ambien and the xanax and
he's like so we've had people that have
gotten completely naked we've had like
you know all kinds of people being very
inappropriate trying to get into other
people's seats and beds and things and I
was like oh yeah that happened to me
once when I was flying with a friend
he's like oh did you take ambien I was
like no no no if it happened to my
friend and I always woken up should like
come take care of her I wonder if that
was that wasn't my frog a so busy and I
worked together in England which this is
how we fell in love we went to England
together and I have always struggle with
insomnia ever since I was a kid when I
was movie called maid of honor guys
don't be jealous I'm sure we're gonna do
a sequel at some point I'm waiting for
that script yeah man obviously I have to
take an ambien for like a 20-minute nap
I mean for me I have to still take an
ambien no I don't got yeah I worked with
Roseanne I'm done with ambien just I
mean every level well it just seems like
it has caused more problems this is just
totally anecdotal yeah I don't have no
basis at all but it's
seems very problematic its problem I
mean I used to take immune when I was in
college in Philadelphia and I would wake
up the next morning after taking one and
there would be like a chicken carcass on
my dining room table yeah there would be
I remember I used to in the middle of
the night eat these things called
LeSueur Peas and I would eat peas in the
middle of the night and I'd have cuts on
my hands with no recollection of it it
was I do the peas look at you because
I'd have to open it was in a can
I'd have to open it from a can and then
I'd open it and then I'd stick my hands
in it and I've got cuts all around my
hand easy it was wild
but you were very committed to that
ambient I was wouldn't give it up but I
also had such weird disordered eating
stuff so I wasn't eating enough during
the day so in the middle of night my
body was like taking the chance to eat
whatever it could and I remember one
time waking up and I was covered in what
I thought was blood and it was barbecue
sauce I had eaten a bottle of barbecue
sauce in the middle of the night and I
woke up I woke up covered in crusty
barbecue sauce I thought I'd been
murdered and I was like if I was
murdered I probably wouldn't be awake it
was just why I mean ambien is wild and
when we did this trip I got up and
changed clothes in front of everyone I
guess so and the flight attendant was
trying to I was asleep not on ambien I
just fell asleep just right yeah I yeah
and the flight isn't it woke me up and
she was like ma'am I need your help
with your friend I don't even remember
in my head your eyes were closed I don't
think they were but you were just like
getting things from overhead that
workers and like slamming the things and
then opening bags and talking and I was
like Whitney Whitney Whitney we gotta
like lay down lay down and I got you
back and laid you down and you were like
oh I just I need I remembered a thing
that I have to get I was like no no no
no no no no it's gonna be fine and then
the worst part of it is we got off the
plane and they said ma'am we have your
duty-free and I had ordered like ten of
those little tiny stuffed planes they're
like $30 apiece
it was a while and I had to beg them to
go like I'm sorry I ordered those nos on
a me and I can't afford that they
so much and what Benton this sounds like
you not on am being shut up this is how
you act anyways I need this I need this
buy 15 of them it's very unbranched I
mean I'm a little bit the same I love I
love you so much for so many reasons but
I do especially love you because you're
still friends with me even though you've
seen me you've seen me in some crazy
moments I'm like a penguin though a
little bit like I like if I bond to you
well here's it here's the thing and we
can we didn't talk about this I don't
really talk I didn't talk about this in
my book and I haven't really ever talked
about this anywhere that's the book it's
it's available in paperback I like the
feel of the paperback meat shoe is
really velvety it's soft velvet velvety
and like matte mm-hmm did I asked for
that look unbelievable
it's really I become friends with people
and I like keep them forever you are one
of the most loyal people I know thank
you that's a really nice compliment but
one thing that I think really draws me
to people and the people that I really
connect with and stick with forever is
trauma and like I just feel it since it
was a person who had trauma you know
like those are the people that I find in
a room right you vibrate on a difference
the oven see I just like find them and
I'm like hi how are you we're gonna be
best friends yeah you're like I'm very
empathic that and we're gonna like stay
together because this is the thing that
we both understand yes and like we can
move through life together with that and
and like it is almost without fail
almost without fair but I think that
when you have similar kinds of trauma
similar parenting some you see the same
things you think the same things are
funny you know you have a shorthand
you're able to tether quicker you know
but I you have a ability to nurture
relationships that I admire so much at
what that's nice it is it is but I also
I'm always trying to find the balance of
like do you ever go you know what this
relationship isn't healthy I have to
call it yes that's one of the hardest
things to do in life
yes yeah is knowing when to be loyal and
stick with it and knowing when it's no
longer serving you yeah I think that is
really tricky and it truthfully has only
kind of happened a few times but because
there's also the other side which is
that we all have I don't know you can
use whatever reward you want to use but
we all have seasons right and like we
all have we all have moments where we're
gonna be for lack of a better word an
asshole yeah to the people who are
closest to us yes and like so a little
bit for me the trick is being able to
like distance in those moments with
people that if that's happening with the
knowledge that like I want to leave it
open I don't wanna blow shit up yeah
because there's no need to yeah and I'd
like to have sugar and I become an
asshole you'll stick with me yeah and
also that there could be there can be
like a thing that comes around yeah you
know and you can and then you're in a
different place together and and and
then hopefully yeah they're returned the
same is true and knowing just when to
distance yourself like I know friends
and I've done this before so many of my
girlfriend's that I thank all I've
reached out to two or three girlfriends
once a week where I'm just like thanks
for sticking with me during that couple
years that you had to watch me be in a
shitty relationship and you were just
you know a lot of times when a girl a
girlfriend starts dating someone who's
just you know recreating their childhood
circumstance it's really hard to watch
you got to just back off till it's over
let it breathe and then come back when
it's done that's right and like you know
I think a lot of people sometimes take
on you just take on too much of the
other person's yep stuff yes like I feel
like I've tried and gotten better at but
it's been it's a process to like figure
out how not to do that and to be able to
but continue to be there and be loyal
and and show up in the ways that I can
and know is okay for me yeah and then
also going yet the way that we're gonna
stay close friends is that I'm gonna
back off a little bit and then catch you
when you get out of that thing mm-hm
or something great yeah I mean yeah
exactly I don't know I feel like you run
a few people that knows how weird I am I
no one believes that I'm a weirdo like
because I also what do they think you
are I think people think
anyone that's funny or like talks
publicly is super confident and good at
socializing oh right yeah yeah and I'm
not that know that socializing no I'm
not gonna socializing and I'm a little
bit socially awkward but there's this
thing now we're calling yourself
socially awkward is very trendy well
it's the whole thing it's the whole this
is like the the downside of social means
you know like like it's like all these
things become like a trend yeah like my
authenticity is like you know whatever
is over ball I can't yeah but everyone
like everyone's dying to have Asperger's
right now like everyone's dying to be
socially awkward I'm sick I'm just so
socially awkward it's like a weird
humblebrag or something now it's like
everyone wants to have been a nerd in
high school you know um but I definitely
am NOT great at socializing and it's
taken me a long time to come to terms
with that but you know that I do know
you believe me I do know that because I
also I also have like invited you to
lots of dinner parties and like I've
seen your interactions not great well I
know you're just you're uncomfortable
it's not easy for you yeah no it's just
not easy for you and like I you could
it's like you can feel it oh you know I
get um I get you know and I've worked
really hard in 12-step programs on my
codependent stuff of not feeling like I
need to perform for people or
shape-shift to be what they want or
always make sure it's at 72 degrees or I
think that when you first met me I was
in two throws in my codependence and was
very much like when I met someone I was
like okay who do I need to become to be
your best friend so that we can entrench
with each other and you know because I
think for me I had such a hard time with
acquaintances like everyone had to be my
best friend or else I felt like it was a
rejection this is something I struggled
with with your husband a little bit too
mark like I didn't know how to just be
an acquaintance with someone and he's
like not he's not a an attached or he's
very self-contained he's very
self-contained he's like we'll talk for
20 minutes and I'll see you next month
right I'm gonna talk for 20 minutes
again and then we'll talk for 20 minute
and I'm like well so are we gonna hike
or mm-hmm
are we gonna make no you're not see you
next month next time I
I see you we're not texting we'll have a
really nice time and I know I'll
remember that you have that thing and he
doesn't feel rejected or I for me I'm
just like okay well now what are we
going to get manis are we good what are
we doing like it's so hard it's hard it
took me a long time to figure out like
who's a good friend who's an
acquaintance who you know like just kind
of like figure out where people belong
it's all so weird in this industry too
and I don't know I know you don't
remember this moment when we were like
cuddling in the back of a van on our
hour drive back into London toward the
end of the maid-of-honor shoot and I
said - because Whitney and I became we
were on set best friends we were like
each other's entire world and humming
but I but this was your first real yes
job that's right and it was like my
eighth natural professional acting job
like a substantial yeah saying and so I
was cuddling with you and I was like
it's gonna be so weird in two weeks when
we don't even know each other anymore
and you're like what are you talking
about you literally are like what are
you talking about I was like Oh Whitney
like this is an onset Romeo that's like
we're just having we're just in love
with each other cuz we're here we'll be
friends but like it's never gonna be
like this again and then which hasn't
been chills down my spine
you were like I really like the collar
drain and you're like what are you
talking about
we don't go back to LA and spend every
day together it's you and me no no no I
was very much this is it now yeah
somehow works I mean we we I again I'm a
penguin mate for life I'm like we're
gonna be friends and we'll be close
friends and you can always call me but
this thing is like this is that man
stunt you were stuff shocking
bone-chilling news but that's what
happens you create these really really
intense intimate relationships we have
bond on sets especially if you're on
location and then when the job ends for
a lot of people it's really difficult
yeah terms with the fact that like that
thing as it existed is never gonna
happen again especially someone that I
think I've largely got into performing
to try and make relationships with
people you know to me I think a lot of
like doing television shows were for me
a way of trying to build like the family
I never had
so I always kind of
heathered too strongly to people in work
situations and was getting internal
needs met externally through work which
is just never healthy yeah so it took me
along but there's so many people that's
also this business like it calls to them
like a fucking siren song it's like oh
you don't have a family
oh you're broken oh you want people to
see you come over here yeah in the
circuit totally I have a bunch of
fucking freaks for you that are gonna be
we're all excited to partner up and like
take you down a path and just have to be
able to like yeah see see it all you
know and I don't know exactly how I well
Linda Cardellini I think had a big deal
had a big part of why I was able to have
that kind of perspective because she
really like laid it out for me when we
did Freaks and Geeks of just like how
this all works yeah how to move through
it and navigate it and stay yourself
yeah I mean it takes a long time when
you sort of are working with someone
every day and you're this amazing
connection and like oh my god this
person like brings me food when I'm
hungry and you're like no they're on
payroll
yes also like I'm never shocked I've
never had one - the bummer but I'm never
shocked when like costars fuck or like
they end up falling in love or any of
that stuff like it's always like oh yeah
obviously I know okay that to me this
drives me nuts cuz it's like okay people
that are statistically some of the most
attractive people on the planet most
charming they got this job because
they're charming they beguiled people
they can make people fall in love with
them through a camera lens and then
you're in hair and makeup in beautiful
wardrobe in a New Zealand for three
months yet you're gonna fuck yeah I know
what a nightmare but I always I think
cuz I of my trauma and like my fear my
fear and my relationship stuff I just
immediately always would bond with the
girls yeah so like I just would like
every set yeah I was like you're not for
me
also actors are the worst but and then
have to justify it by like building a
whole other world around it that they're
like method and that it's this whole
like dark thing that they have to wade
through it's like do you just like bully
pretend what who win awards for
pretending might not be trustworthy um
yes but I yes but I feel like I sort of
sidestepped like would always sidestep
that a little bit by like bonding with a
lady was that unlike creating that
relationship that bond people tried to
set us up as friends before we met
mm-hmm
I heard about you before I met you I
heard a lot of people would be like
you've got to be friends of business you
got to meet busy gotta be busy everyone
said it to me when I first moved to LA
and I like had heard about you cuz you
were like the person to beat at
auditions it was like if bizzy's testing
just don't go and so I had heard about
Wilde I was very into me I was very
intimidated by you
and then I wasn't you gotta meet busy
and then when I first met you I was like
hey everyone thinks we should meet and
you're like yeah so what you're like
loud okay sounds like oh wow look at you
you have big features and you're loud
yeah but I do think a lot of people
think that's true I forgot about that
oh is that what you're loud you have a
big laugh yeah yeah really confident
women that always goes great but I think
that um I think that socializing can be
really hard for me because I think
people assume that if someone is
ostensibly funny or ostensibly loud I
think a lot of people conflate someone
who's a performer with someone who's
confident mm-hmm I became a performer
because I was not confident right so in
social situations I'm not I'm I think I
feel pressure to be funny I feel
pressure to deliver I'm not gonna get
naked and like jump in the nacho dip
like that's not who I am and sometimes I
feel pressure a lot of people end up
wanting to be friends that's you're on
ambien unless I'm on ambien in which
case I'm a fucking blast
that's all bets are off but a nacho
people think that I'm gonna be like like
I don't know like to have crazy stories
and stuff and it feels like pressure to
me and then I leave being kind of
exhausted cuz I feel like I have to
perform and then I've worked so hard to
not have relationships that are based on
being authentic you know cuz you can
make a lot of friends if you pretend and
are on and are performing and then
they're like oh god I've made this
friend based on the person I'm
pretending to be every time I see them I
have to act and I'm exhausted yeah and I
also used to get in a relationship based
on who I could like rescue and
here take well yeah yeah yeah so I
started to have like a lot of like I
didn't trust my instincts on we hadn't
we had that too we dated that in common
yes I don't know if I did that with
friends though really as much I
definitely did I was like I would
breastfeed you if I could but I think a
lot of people rescued me also a little
bit yeah sure I was the opposite for a
lot of people but just any kind of like
drama finding yourself in relationships
that are really dramatic their cars oh
they're always locked out of their car
and their tires are always flat and
always you know the right those are like
math I can't deal with those that was I
was like I'm those people are messing my
entire 20s was that there's a lot of
those people in your 20s and you it's
really hard to play defense against that
kind of energy because I think if you're
empathic or just a compassionate person
you want to be able to like help and fix
and show up but it's not you're not
taking care yourself if you're taking
care the other person maybe a long time
yeah
to tell the difference what's being a
good friend and what's being a
codependent right yeah I mean yeah I
don't know I have to I just
I'm I do everything like based on my
intuition and then most of the time it
works out and occasionally it hasn't but
I am good at like at recognize I have
you know what I will say yeah I just had
this conversation with my friend Jen
gosh I I'm very I'm self-aware and like
a very self-aware person wildly and so
self-awareness like is the key for me in
Denton's of like how I what's happening
and now I'm relating and how they're
relating to me and like what actually is
going on yeah cuz I'm able to kind of
see it yeah it took me a long time to
get there were you always that way I
don't know I can't I don't think so no I
don't think so it took me a long time I
think my twenties I was very delusional
about the way I was perceived and what
did you think I thought that nobody
liked I just didn't think I was worth
anyone's time right I thought I had to
be funny in order to like earn someone's
attention you worked harder than anyone
I've ever known in my life truly and I
work fucking hard and you like you the
hustle you had when we met I was in awe
I was just like I didn't even understand
it I was like why are you setting your
alarm and waking up and writing these
jokes for some fucking dude to say on
thank you don't even get to say the
jokes are you kidding the fuck is that
they paying you they're not even paying
you why aren't they paying you I'll
Whitney don't you work for free like and
you're like what I don't this is just
what I did this is how it works you're
gonna leave my house to go do like a
10:00 p.m. set and then leave again then
come back and then leave again for a
11:45 what is happening used to do that
I would ride so hard to balance doing
stand-up and having friends I would I
would I remember having dinner at your
house leaving to go do stand-up at the
Comedy Store at like 9:00 and then
coming back at like 10:00 yeah and then
leaving again for your midnight set
that's right and then coming back yeah
and I just to me I was like well that's
not sustainable hence why I look 20
years older than I am you do collagen is
not sustainable okay do you want to hear
depressing
yeah I'm worse Asian I had with my 11
year old yes at the Century City Mall
yes we were at the Century City Mall and
I left my hydro flask in the car and I
need water
yeah and so I don't want to walk down it
was a Saturday I'm already exhausted
parenting you know like my kids Saturday
at noon can't fathom it and like I don't
wanna go to the car to get it I guess I
have to go get a car this is I'm just
saying this out loud as we're sitting
there in the food court and birdie goes
just buy a bottle of water mom my 11 oh
just buy it just buy a plastic bottle of
water mom and I was like well I know but
I'm really you know I'm really trying to
like be aware not eliminate my
single-use plastic because of the
climate crisis in the environment and
she goes it doesn't matter I was like
what and she's like I mean they need to
make governments need to make change
like corporations need to make change
you're buying this water bottle isn't
gonna matter we have like 50 years on
the outside I mean you guys will
probably be dead but crooked and I are
definitely gonna see the end of
civilization and I was like she I mean I
know we are wrong and then age
capitalism crying hysterically which is
like of course what she kind of wanted
and then and Mark was like can't believe
you fell for it I can't believe you
walked right into that busy
and then I just went I was like fine and
I went bought a plastic bottle of water
are you happy and she's like no I'm just
whatever it's fine mom whatever yeah
your notic you can't beat yourself up
but the meat thing is I think it's
280,000 liters of water for each cow
that's how much it takes it's just wild
so for me it's like okay the easiest
thing is to like cut out meat like I
know that even if I buy that blass
plastic bottle water or whatever like if
I just don't need so much meat like I'm
doing something right you ready to play
a game okay
you're gonna tell me your favorite
animal uh-huh your favorite article of
clothing and your favorite body of water
let's start with your favorite animal
and I know you're gonna maybe jump like
cat or your cats or something your
favorite animal in terms of the one you
admire the most I love a personality
test did I ever tell you about the one
Jamie Foxx said to me no I won't have to
tell you at some point time now it's the
only time I've ever met Jamie Foxx but
it was a wild time
and he did the boat one have you done
the bow no give it to me wow so Whitney
Whitney you're on a boat what kind of
boat are you on canoe okay and you're on
a body what kind of water what's what
you're on a lake yeah and what's the
what's the water doing is the water
still is it is it is it wavy I'm growing
through it so it's rippling its rippling
its rippling is there anyone in the
canoe nope no it's just you alone what
do you see when you look you're in the
lake what do you see myself I'm taking a
picture but you're taking a picture of
yourself while rowing the boat yeah but
what's in the background of the picture
anything trees just trees just trees you
can see the shore yeah third but there's
a bunch of dead bodies on the shore okay
yeah all right mm-hmm that this all
makes sense yeah no I don't know I don't
know what it was obviously flirting with
you no he wasn't it was like that's like
the game or some shit what it wasn't
exactly I'm lying it was wild it was
like he had this was a million years ago
and Olivia Munn and I had had some idea
for a movie and she was like we should
take it to Jaime and I was like okay
yeah and she was like Jaime wants us to
come to his house and like pitch it to
him and so we and I she like was friends
with him good friends with him or knew
him or whatever and so we showed up
to his house but he wasn't there yet and
so we were we always and then was a nice
house yeah it was like it's close here I
live near there was random celebrities
for those of you that are just listening
and have no idea where I live which I
hope you don't don't look it up on
reddit I live near some very random
celebrities including Jamie Foxx and
Scott Baio and uh and it was birdie was
baby and I was just like panicked about
getting back to see her at some point
you know like it was yeah so far away
and I felt like rush hour was coming
yeah and anyways Anisha it's so fuckin
rude to make it a point with someone and
be late it's crazy to me and it happens
with big celebrities all the time but
they're doing a lot I don't care that's
what scheduling is for I have never been
late for a meeting in my life have I
been tin except when you were dyslexic
and put appointments wrong down in my
you've never been late and technically
you weren't late then you just missed an
entire flight yeah because you put the
time in wrong just before Benton told me
he was dyslexic you're dyslexic yeah
we'll go with that this is my favorite
bedding company it's called Buffy it's
also been Ted's favorite TV show and the
bedding i watch Buffy wrapped in Buffy
Buffy pillows it's a great time this
stuff is amazing it's earth-friendly
cruelty-free bedding we've spent
sleepless nights worrying about the
impact the betting industry has on the
environment so we decided to change it
good for you Buffy their products are
made using only sustainable and recycled
materials which makes them soft on the
planet as they are on your bed and tush
our latest product is called breeze it's
a comforter made entirely from ah a
hundred percent
eucalyptus fiber to regulate temperature
and keep the body cool see I like this
because normally it's goose goose
feathers and I don't want to be a
wrapped up in blue feather this
comforter it regulates your temperature
it doesn't kill any geese to breathe
baby fabric inside
cruelty free this is reason alone to
freaking buy these for $20 off your
Buffy comforter visit Buffy dot co-ceo
and enter the code Whitney that's me
that's $20 off your Buffy comforter
visit Buffy dot CE o and enter code
Whitney don't be a fool Donald Duck it's
interesting I find dyslexia really
interesting yeah you it's numbers minor
words I can flate words and sometimes
it's because I have a migraine coming on
and I also have a little bit of a speech
impediment but I think yours is number
one it's just I'm the part of your brain
that processes the language mine goes
too fast and so I used to stutter
because of it so like if I have to look
at words and numbers and like calendars
and stuff I have to look like really
focused or I just start writing just
whatever Oh God
I had um I occasionally I don't not in a
few years but I used to suffer from
stress induced aphasia where like words
would just disappear yeah and I couldn't
and I was it's you know it's wild or I
would say the wrong yep I would replace
word that's a big like nonsensical oh no
no like so would be like do you want to
go let's go take the Elephant escalator
the escalator let's go it's like next to
each other and I hit the campus and they
conflate I do that to run like the
etymology etiology like one of them and
then I just get sort of lost yeah
there's also like just not knowing the
right word there's also the fact that
I'm illiterate ah there's also the fact
that I'm completely full of shit and I
pretend to no words mean and I don't
well anyway Jamie Foxx showed up and the
first and he was like it's so nice to
meet you
busy I have a quick walk with me you're
on a boat and he like did the whole
thing to me and then like basically like
broke down my personality based on that
and I was like this is strange but okay
like alright and then we like I mean he
was nice it wasn't like strange like in
a bad way it was just like I've just
never stuck it just was a wild moment
time I was plus I was probably still I
was probably still suffering from
postpartum anxiety and I wasn't
medicated so it was like there was a lot
going on for me you know what's so
interesting cuz I feel like I know you
so well but I have no idea how this is
gonna go I need to know your favorite
animal
and three reasons that why basically
three adjectives to describe the animal
I mean it's this is so hard like there's
so many I have no idea where you're
gonna pick either it's kind of blowing
my mind the animal you admire admire
like I picked honeybadger because I
think they're badasses they fight lions
but they're really small and they're
just cool as shit and they're scrappy
you know a lot about animal I do see
this is also I feel like I'm at a
deficit I don't know that many animal I
know like the big ones yeah the ones we
all know like the main ones the main
guys envy animals I got the top five of
the animals and then my kinder kids so
you've had to you know some zoology I
mean it I mean I again I think I was in
the area of Dolphin elephant horse
probably would have in my second I know
anything about them to what you can pick
any what would yours be about 10
starfish really watch spongebob
unfortunately unfortunately SpongeBob's
like my favorite show of all time
oh man I love it it has notes on lots of
things people love wheat but also I
didn't love a spongebob until I had
cricket and it was crickets favorite
show and really has been instrumental in
developing her very absurd sense of
humor which I tied directly to her love
of spongebob but anyway just when you
say starfish it reminds me of Patrick
starfish I mean it'd be weird if you
love spongebob well I'm used to baby so
much of kids and they watched all the
times I think in my head I'm just like
this other you associated with other
kids besides you getting love from your
mother oh that's right okay that's
traumatizing
wait okay I really admire elephants
that's a good one I really do like them
mm-hmm those are great animals and I
guess I guess I also love a panda bear
panda bears are pretty great and I
really like dogs like just like dogs are
so cute I like puppies yeah but I like
with small things like I'm small in age
things like I like babies of all kinds
yeah even like any baby animals Wow any
baby fucking and
because we could be Muppets or my
favorite Muppet the baby my bad it's a
bum up at babies it's a bum up it's not
an animal all right it's just the puppet
I didn't have a childhood I don't know
about you no no okay
but Muppet Babies were the best of the
Muppets
um but any baby theni babies that what
you're gonna people you know it
collected beanie baby I didn't know I
had a huge beanie where are they now
well I still I had kept a couple and
birdie has some and I mean pretty birdie
has them but now my they've rebranded
Whitney and they're now called beanie
boos and they have giant eyes it's a
whole new shtick it's not they're not
filled with beanbags
they're not like little beanbags they're
little tiny stuffed animals that have
giant eyes and they look like like you
know and but stay but same idea like
they come with the birthday and a name
and where they were born and they sell
them in airports and it's the thing that
I bring my children when I'm traveling
yeah and and like on like a kiosk in
their Hudson news yes and crickets
obsessed with them and and I every time
I buy one
I feel like an 80s dad that's traveling
for work every time just cheated on his
wife and I'm trying to get a get a
favorite time no not the wife no just
like you know like in a movie
yeah yeah it was like the 80s dad with
like a trench coat on and he like he
like hastily stops it like the gift
store in the airport and like gets up
for the kid but by the end of the movie
they're like playing ball and he's like
giving up the career and he's not
traveling anymore like every fucking
time I picture you just as catherine
o'hara and home alone
yeah i'm wearing that's exactly right
that's how I travel and like a mahogany
suit I wish I was so fashionable I used
to why I used to look at like people mad
calm and I would see Jessica Alba like
airport photos or or you know and I
would just be like how how does she look
like that traveling I look not like that
I invested recently in some flying suits
I'd like to talk to you about that when
I travel I look like I just got out of
rehab yeah I look like a pajama girl
wearing pajamas in rehab
yeah that travels that Trek I try every
way
now yeah I travel sittin no zippers no
buttons mmm just you know like you know
when I'm the things you have to wear an
insane asylum so you can't hang yourself
that's how I dressed in an airport cozy
yeah
cozy oh well I bought the AAF I bought
two flying suits which are just like
track suits but they're fancy yeah and I
got these compression leggings and saw
oh yeah I have to get up and walk back
and forth but also compression yeah it's
great I should do that very into it yeah
I've noticed a difference you're good at
flying oh yeah I am now mmhmm yeah I
usually not baby I do the whole thing
noise cancelling headphones ostrich
pillow bombs in lick in stick form Bom
Bom everywhere Vaseline in the nose I
got I mean what you've seen me fly I do
not play around when I fly I'm hardcore
shit I was sitting next to someone on an
airplane and they said um oh it's so
nice to meet you whatever you know we
were my my am my friend and I were on a
flight a couple years ago and we saw an
actress flying and I mean her whole
routine before the plate and I was like
was it Whitney no up until that very I
was but she did like she was like you
you actor cuz I had because I also how
about I want fun I have a whole thing
I'd like a moisturizer oh yeah face
mouth whole thing I hired ray I also
become the camp counselor of the flight
any flight I'm on I start calling
bullshit on people if they're eating
something weird if they're listening to
headphones too loud if they start
talking on the phone I get up and I'm
the one that confronts people I was
flying to Texas like six or seven months
ago and a woman had a bag of hard-boiled
egg absolutely and I went nope not today
or if like someone's headphones you can
hear the music through the headphones
I'm like you need to turn it I get very
involved in making sure it's interesting
I would be terrified oh and I would I
mean and I couldn't do that I think I
would say so I would go up to the galley
yeah and talk to the flight crew mm-hmm
I mean like 5c has a bag of hard-boiled
and you'd better get on that I just do
it myself I get so angry the fact that
you don't think everyone here paid money
to share the space with you and you're
gonna eat a bunch of farts is wild to me
okay am I going am I in
and Maya panda they also I like how your
I like what you're doing with this baby
panda thing and this baby elephant thing
like baby elephants are the fucking cute
beyond comprehension well I love inside
the fourths most intelligent animal
maybe the third that's me I think you're
a baby elephant I think I'm a baby
elephant I think you're a baby out with
that
so three words to describe a baby
elephant
I mean don't kill so cute so smart and
so playful okay mm-hmm
so the next one this might be hard for
just not because my favorite article of
clothing is address a specific one Oh
does it have to be specific if it could
be oh I think it'd be ideal if it was
because at first I was like ha I was
like this gallon that I love so much
that I wore once or and then I ended up
doing hoodie no yeah well that's what I
would have picked for you yeah oh how
dare you you know me too well
like a mini backpack and a hoodie that's
so few people remember that I used to
carry a little mini backpack that ever I
was your all-time so alright so fuck it
so my jean jacket okay mm-hmm three are
things to describe it well but that's
like it's a it's my like security
blanket okay so say it's like tough so
it's like no it's like uh it's not
armored but it's kind of like protection
uh-huh protective it's protective it's
practical mm-hmm it's protective and
practical and I mean this is whatever
but it is loyal I've had like you know
I've had it for a really long time
mm-hmm I love that interesting now your
favorite body of water this is where I
thought Jamie Foxx might be going when
it just turned into nothing particularly
and well I don't I don't know I don't
remember what the thing is I think I can
look that one up yeah I want to know
it's the boat is something yeah who's on
the boat with the fact that you're alone
is something what you see is done but
it's also your target was
liberty and I'm in your house like I'm
just trying to get through this quiz
pitch you this movie yeah I was like I
think I said a speedboat oh I wasn't
driving Oh
interesting interesting my family was
with me yeah it wasn't like a fancy
speedboat it was just like an like a
boat you would take if we were on the
ocean I could see the shore uh-huh and
yeah my kids were with me and wearing
life vests yeah so there's something to
be said about I think I picked canoe
alone in a lake oops suicide watch call
I think you were like a very insular
person I'm a very um isolate isolate
myself I am introverted what you and
Merc are very similar I know I know
and you look like my exploits ouch a lot
of people if you have read this book
Craig who features heavily on the second
half of the book I'm getting sweaty like
it's so hot and you don't look at like
no no one won't do that no one will see
that I'm sad for me when I get up so
when I know I'm sliding in ass I'm
currently sitting in swamp I'm wearing a
sweater that I wore especially for you I
remember I was sitting in a makeup chair
I didn't have any makeup on yet and my
hair was back in like a low bun or
something and Bizzy looked over at me
and was like oh my god you know what you
exactly like my ex-boyfriend Craig and I
was like I've been trying to place it
for so long as we've been working
together like who does Whitney look like
who does she remind me of and I was like
it was my it's my ex-boyfriend Craig and
you're like ouch fuck yeah you did you
guys you favorite each other you put
pictures side-by-side of us I did I did
a split screen you guys were just like
you were like good you know you're like
the female like oh you were like a
female version but not anymore though oh
really
oh I don't think so I mean haven't seen
I don't know we don't speak but um I
found that when I wrote a book a bunch
of people reached out to me apologizing
and wanting to fight about it I was like
that wasn't about you
I think that was about you like people
just we're so desperate to have been the
person that harmed me Oh interesting
they all really I'm sorry I had no idea
I got very specific email you
yeah yeah cuz I'm mad because I really
named ya I was impressed as shit I was
like damn this is brave and I you know
but for the most imeem for the whole
part the whole part yeah honestly I feel
fine about it and I'm and I still do and
you know I love that um that quote
what's her name
you know her narrator know I love Bernay
she Commons oh my Instagram the other
day and that was like that's pretty big
deal what's her name she wrote the book
on how to write things Elizabeth Gilbert
no like she wrote a book on how to write
called bird by bird but she also has
written some really incredible novels
and Wow
and she's from Marin County my favorite
and she has a she has a pretty famous
quote that I'm sure you've heard if
people wanted you to write warmly about
them they should have behaved better I
love it I love it so much it's called
accountability folks if people wanted
you to write warmly about them mmm-hmm
they should have treated they should
have behaved better I should have
consequences that's all you seem like
you really enjoyed writing your book
like when I was reading it it was very
like writing about this is what got me
through it you know and that was really
impressive to me I did not like writing
a book I don't say I don't think I liked
it oh really
no I think me feel better no I don't
think I really like that right now in
the but you like having written it I
like having written them yeah everything
like all right me to everything that you
write yeah I felt like yeah and I felt a
great sense of accomplishment and I felt
really good about the things that I
wrote and I felt that it did the thing
that I sat out and what I wanted it to
do and sort of like the thesis of it and
I feel like I was really successful in
writing the book that I want to try it
and that's all like you could ask for it
I just think it's important that people
know it's hard it's really hard it's
really awful it's really
and if you especially if you actually
write your fucking book that's right and
a lot of people cuz a lot of people
don't that was the thing I didn't know
just said that because when I wrote my
book everyone's like so did you write it
I was like we're not talking it was that
an option yeah no one tells you you're
allowed to not write and then I was like
so who's gonna record your audio sir I
think there are people that like
immediately they're like well you're not
writing your book like you know what I
mean you know do you know what I'm
saying yeah no no yeah no no I mean the
people that represent you know I was
sure I was letting that to the people
like the publishers like they're like I
want to make a book deal with
ex-celebrity yeah but they're not gonna
write the book so what's like bring them
this deal yeah and tell them that will
support them and get a writer and like
all of that stuff yeah make it like
really good for them to do yeah and then
I think there are people like you
because you're a writer and because
you're comedian and me because I have a
lot of thoughts and you but you're so
specific and I'm very so and very I
could have gotten a ghostwriter for sure
I'm sure I could have because a lot of
times the ghost writers just talk to
them on the phone that's right and then
they just like kind of transferred in
them they record your conversations and
then they transcribe it or whatever I
think for me there was a lot of things
and I feel like you maybe had this dude
there's a lot of things that I had never
told anybody and for the first time I
ever wrote it expressed it had it out of
my brain in any iteration was in my book
and I wouldn't even be brave enough to
tell a ghostwriter about it right I
would have been too embarrassed but I
remembered I first turned in the first
transcript it was basically a quantum
estuve or step in a 12-step program
which is when you do your inventory and
you basically tell your secrets to
somebody so you stop carrying shame
around and I remember that's how he's
treating it and then when I first turned
it in they're like great we're going to
print I had a pit in my stomach and I
felt so sick and I was like oh no people
can't read this right like I don't even
actually read this right I like I didn't
think it through or something so I felt
like a lot of fear around it and a lot
of embarrassment and even today when
someone says they read it I'm like can
we make eye contact with them Oh
interesting yeah I go too embarrassed I
wrote stuff in there that I've like came
and I still have been denial about oh
that's interesting to me that's what a
book was for me it was like stuff that I
was too ashamed to talk about on stage
or too ashamed to talk about like I
didn't really do a lot of interviews
about it cuz I'd like didn't I talk
about love addiction I talk about eating
disorders and hey I know you know sexual
assault like it was stuff that I was
just like wouldn't even do press about
it yeah because I was like I don't know
how to make this money well it's it's
interesting I was like very I felt like
the process of doing it I had the same
fears obviously and I and even in the
book like write about it a little bit
it's like my biggest fear was having
things that were deeply personal to me
and deeply important to me being reduced
to like a clickbait yep headline and
like five shocking revelation yeah busy
and I'm like that happened that didn't
happen which is part of the game and but
I had like the entire time while I was
writing it was very aware that that was
an eventualities I was going to have to
face because I'm aware of like again cuz
I'm software but because I'm aware of
like how people see me and how people in
the and the specific ways people are
interested in me right and like all of
those things like I had a whole thing
that I was like very prepared for what I
was not prepared for and naively so I
think in retrospect was that the James
Franco story was going to get be the one
that became like the whirlwind
you know three-day non-stop news cycle
internet mishegoss but it was because I
didn't I didn't think that that would be
the thing because he and I had like
publicly spoken about that story on
stage at like sketch fest together and
then I talked about it on watch what
happens live like two years earlier but
in light of me to and the me it had some
allegations I haven't like no part of or
whatever I guess that became the thing
that people like really put their hooks
into and I was like and then you find
yourself having a conversation with the
publicist where I'm like but like really
not the abortion yeah like really like
they're not even like like but like no
one's picking up the abortion okay I
mean I guess I guess like that'll make
my mom
and her like you know friends and
Arizona like she'll be happy that she
doesn't have to explain my abortion
we're friends in Arizona I guess but
like Jesus really of course is not the
right James Franco right you know what I
mean like I'm less it's wild and then
it's kind of like was my rape rejected
yeah the media yeah wasn't my abortions
not good enough for you yeah my abortion
ended up being good enough he does it
did get it all all came back around yeah
that's really what it was about
I have a special publicist for my
abortion I brought on a new team but I
think like once I started to once that
happened because it was right before the
book came out I was so stressed out
about that like it was really upsetting
because of Franco of it all that part
like it because because lipst everything
else it Clips everything else and it was
like really my thesis in writing the
whole book was that I wanted to present
and give my account of what it has been
like to be a woman coming of age in this
particular time world and then in this
industry in this particular time in the
world and like what my experience was
and like moving forward and how we move
forward and all of these things and then
all the fucking headlines were reduced
to being about a dude yeah yeah Ted I
worked with and when he fucking years
ago and I was like uh I was like shit I
should have just like and the thing
that's so frustrating is I had that was
the only thing where I was like fuck I
should have just left it out yeah but
but and this is a huge but that was my
first job that was where I learned that
if you are like a beautiful dude who is
an actor you can get away with anything
and if you are girl you show up and shut
the fuck up and hit your mark and know
your lines better and like starve
yourself and get thin and all of these
things like that was where that was like
so very clearly given to me that gift
even though Paul and Judd and Jake
Kasdan the people in charge of that
particular show we're trying to do their
best to like mitigate that messaging to
me and Linda by telling us I please
don't die at girls like please you guys
are amazing like don't we love you the
way you are blah blah blah blah blah
like the message didn't matter because
the network you know the people in
charge give the message yeah great I
don't think people understand and I'm so
glad you said it
in the book about just how big of a
shithole this business is so wild to me
that it's so shocking to everyone that
this business is bad like it's like in
it we haven't even scratched the surface
it's like you know I told this story in
my special about this director who the
first time I was ever taft-hartley I'm
on a show to have like two lines on a
show or whatever the director invited me
into his trailer for lunch he was 65 I
was 19 and I told the story about going
in there and did it up and everyone's
asked me the directors name the
directors name
who's the director and you know I like
trying to not make it a story but all I
can think about is now that I've been on
a lot of sets since then now that I've
actually directed a movie I understand
that there's like 15 people whose only
job is to watch what the director is
doing all day where is he he's walking
to set he's walking there he's in the
bath is in his room 15 people watched me
at 19 go into a trailer with a 65 year
old married guy and of course there was
not much they could do back then but
there were so many accomplices to that
and when people talk about the Harvey
stuff it's like there are many agents
and managers who set these meetings up
like the number of the not alone will
number of people that enabling this
happening is so wild but it just it
shocks me when people think that
Hollywood is girls I'm like yes Benton I
have a question before you get up topic
and I don't mean to ask the question but
do you both of you being in this
industry do you feel like that's
changing what you just talked about I
don't know what I mean to LA the the
word the most traumatic eating stuff I
got was from two stylists who told me I
should do cocaine to lose weight
yeah the stylist I talked about that in
my book because the most body shame I
would ever feel was um in a wardrobe
fitting yeah with the stylist yeah and
that was when I really was given the
message and not on Freaks and Geeks Deb
McGuire did not do that and I've worked
with her since on other shows and she
never she's not that that's not who she
is and not just Deb there are plenty of
incredible stylists in wardrobe
people who don't do that thing yeah but
my experience in the late 90s and early
2000s there were a lot who did there
were a lot who but even post made him
honor I did a very small job that I've
been offered on a very on a show and you
know they get sent your sizes ahead of
time like all your measurements every
it's not just your sizes they get sent
your actual like my waist is this my
hips are the my which for women changed
everyday really it does but like I'm
within you know within the thing the you
know of stuff whatever and they went
into this fitting and like she had
polled I I was at the time and I was
really skinny when we did maid of honor
cuz remember I remember yeah I just done
I just got married and I was we were
like eating hummus and I was and I was
like stressed stressed about my wedding
and I we were drinking like coffee and
eating hummus all day and I was at like
peak of my eating disorder in that time
we would like go to Whole Foods and just
eat like vegetables it was wild everyone
yeah so so I was but this is just to say
like I was not and this is like weird
that I'm even justifying it as I'm
telling the story
like because I've varied in weight my
entire Kurt like my career since I
started when I was 19 years old
yes weird you know like I've been bigger
I've been smaller and blah blah blah
blah and but this was a particular time
where I was very tiny I would say and
from for me for anyone I was like a size
four probably and I showed up to the
fitting and she had all zeroes polled
that's that that was all she had all she
had to try to get me into were size
zeros so then I'm just like like by his
by the way this dress is a size 10
because I just like wanted it and it was
like a size 10 I was like why I I don't
I don't give a fuck about sizes I don't
weigh myself anymore smart love that
don't I haven't weighed myself since I
was yes required to buy a facilitate
when I was 15 yeah I got rid of it yes I
was I used to be really like wait this
also means nothing because the more
muscle mass you have the heavier you're
gonna eat and you see no strong yeah I
was gonna say you're so much like you
can lose fat and gain muscle in your
action to be gaining weight and water
weight you're different you're a
different weight every hour of the day
yeah so but
yeah and I just had that I went back to
the I had done I felt like I had been
gotten to a place where I was good and
not focused on that shit yeah and then I
went into that thing and I had like a
whole spiral
yeah and was like it was like it was
crazy making it's not okay and she was
then the way she was like acting she was
like oh I guess I don't know we can I
guess we're gonna have to do another
poll we'll have to do another
passive-aggressive but you should have
done the fucking poll in the first place
because I'm not a size zero yes and my
fucking sizes and you're under all this
pressure because it's like you want to
deliver like you don't you might lose a
job and they just look so disappointed
like I guess we're gonna have to go back
to Barney's mmm because you failed yeah
you failed me and they'll see my not
being something what I don't fucking
know yeah and yeah and then I lost a job
because I hadn't I haven't lost my baby
weight I didn't get a job because I
hadn't lost my baby weight and the and
the network rejected me it's all
complicated it's all the body stuff
culturally in this world is complicated
and I think that like the magazine
industry is doing an ad agency is I mean
I think that they're I think they are
making an a concerted effort I think a
lot of beauty brands I think a lot of
people and are they're doing because
they have to it's like Karl Lagerfeld
didn't stop using know what yeah that's
right it's actually an economic
imperative your business is gonna fail
if you don't do this and that is the
best way to make change happen for sure
so it's exciting to just go we're not
doing this because we're trying to be
progressive this is actually just what
people want now you know right which I
prefer I do too and I'm performative
woke nuts and I'm glad that people have
been vocal and I think the Internet has
a lot to do with that too yeah you know
because you're able to have immediate
feedback we're in an industry where
there's like a finite amount of jobs
available you know and like you want to
eliminate the variables like and so
weight was a variable for women for a
long time your body was a variable and
like if you could make it to what the
like cultural ideal at the time was you
like eliminated that variable of why
they couldn't give you the job and so
now you only had to
with your hair color your eye color what
your face looked like and then you had
to contend with your talent yeah that's
right
so if you know so like it was definitely
think I mean I will say I think that
because of the Kardashians and the
popularity of them like the mass
popularity of those women the sort of
cultural ideals on bodies have shifted
since the 90s when I started and when
you were you know in the throws of all
of your stuff because you know Kate Moss
was the ideal when I in you know when I
was in high school like the waif and
they wanted really skinny girls and all
the girls like you know when I was
starting out like all like being curvy
was not that was not a pro like people
were not interested in my classic
hourglass would not have been killing it
in the 90s was not a thing that what
we're looking for that's what actual
straight men were looking for with that
is not what Hollywood was looking for I
think it's real important to remember
like I travel over the country and some
people listen to podcast mothers go like
what the fuck you guys talking about
this wolf most women look like that body
positivity is not a problem in America
is a problem in Hollywood but that super
important cuz we mass-produce the images
that go around the world so it is
important but most women average the
size 16 most men love curving women
they're married to them body positivity
outside of LA and New York is alive and
well wanting to fuck someone doesn't
necessarily line up with their body yes
that's right that's just like yeah so
it's dumb and basic yes like it doesn't
it's like yeah you want to fuck someone
because you like have a fucking thing
with them that's right it is not because
you're like oh yeah she does not have
the measurements but I'm looking for oh
that's like you're like no it's like a
vibe and like a thing that's it I feel
like you're trying to get out of this
body of water thing okay I love an ocean
I you love an ocean yeah I'm an ocean
what about an ocean oh I love the
vastness vast what else I need a couple
more
just to describe ocean well I like um
well I like a specific kind of like I
like a like a body of water that's like
big waves do we like little LAPI waves
like salmon oh I like we're clear okay
so okay like kind of like ocean the
roughest shit
yeah I've been oh but I'm thinking about
you like South Carolina yeah
but South Carolina is not clear though
okay I'm completing my bodies of water
okay in one in my clear nose that's like
I guess my favorite is like Caribbean
yeah so that's a warm okay wait so
that's my face almost like Caribbean but
I got an ocean what is that it's about
it is I'm asking okay so so it's so it's
clear like you can see it's like crystal
look beautiful haha gallo uh-huh
well like just not deep like Maldives
have you the Maldives it's a Maldivian
know I like Turks and Caicos yep yep yep
okay so you like that blue like really
blue here and like you can walk out for
a mile mm-hmm I see you like a shelf you
like a shelf like a shelf I've always
liked it but I like a shelf in South
Carolina - do you like waves
do you like the roughness or do you like
the placid nature of it well I like a
wave where I can like be floating and
have it wave me not something okay I
think we can ascertain quite a bit here
so this is a test that as you all know
dr. Freud developed in order to figure
out who people are instead of who they
pretend to be you're so self aware there
will not be a lot of surprises here your
favorite animal represents how you see
yourself mm-hmm
how you see yourself baby elephant smart
cute and playful mm-hmm is that track at
all sure and your favorite article of
clothing is how other people perceive
you okay you're a denim jacket
protective practical and loyal yes and
your favorite body of water is how you
view sex beautiful shallow and I like it
to carry me away to undo some word
association I love it
okay word association all right so
you're just gonna respond as fast as you
can okay this is hard for me all right
okay okay I know we tell you and look at
you yeah ready uh-huh
mom I mean I don't know I just literally
just thought of Barbara Phillips and I
just like great thought I just yeah I'm
very literal sometimes that's a good
thing I like especially like I dream my
dreams are very like obvious like I
don't have it there's not a lot to wade
through in my dream really helpful
because if you're playing word
association with so much I highly
encourage when you're meeting somebody
new and you're trying to find red flags
and people if they're literal the way
you're being literal right now that's
good right that I I talked about the
other day when I had someone on I once
played word association about a year too
late in a relationship with somebody and
I said because my therapist told me to
start doing it with people because I
just couldn't see red flags to save my
life and when I did I would like paint
them green and I said woman and the guy
went cunt
no I was like wish I had done this test
a year ago that makes me sad ready it's
wrong with people
yeah blood I mean weirdly I thought of
Bon Iver I mean because I was thinking
of the blood bank song deep ocean thank
you you guys I can't I'm not really bad
about wet my vagina I sweat every part
of my body is wet always always
I'm not wet as person I know I'm serious
oh I don't know sec I don't know I don't
have anything sick I don't know anything
wait I mean sinuses yeah easy Sigurd
it's like too emotionally healthy for
this game you're just very clear and
literal safe home man actually was my
immediate response man woman
child birdie my first one beer alone
money lots money lot money la Hollywood
no I think that's that that doesn't
smell of the damn thing rough sex
cricket my baby I feel like you've
passed that with flying colors
that was impressive a shit the the more
clear and direct your word Association
answer the more mentally healthy and
well-adjusted someone is you win man
woman is the only other that's the rap
the only that's the only rub fear alone
there's something there maybe well no
shit that's what we're doing my therapy
I deal with that a lot but in your
motorboat you had someone in there
yeah but I'm very like family-focused
because I'm a mom yeah different I mean
some moms are really narcissistic and
like you know but I I think becoming a
mom for me took me way outside myself I
feel like a lot of people responded
positively
i can'twe on this because I don't have
children that's where my speech
impediment comes in have you noticed I
just skip words just like full like are
the conjunctions what are the things
that connect words and sentences I just
skip them like and I'm also putting
pressure myself because I feel like you
have to be somewhere but a lot of people
responded to when you said that you ask
your kids permission before you post
them on social media
oh well yeah I mean I look it's I have
no I'm sure this is true this is fucking
true and I don't and it's not even like
if you stopped this I would tell you
something differently I have no fucking
judgment on anyone treats their kids or
snow or does
anything on social no visa via social
means yeah
because first of all we don't fucking
know we don't know
so who fucking know we don't know so
like your choice to like put a sticker
over their face my choice to like ask
their permission our choice to just
fucking post every photo of them shit
yeah you know like who'd fucking know
the fact that people now are like we
have to protect our kids like we used to
give a roll of film with photos of your
kids to a fucking stranger I think
people have like I think people have
lots of different motivations yeah
beyond an eye and I personally am like
open to all things being right yeah yeah
and that's all right for you or right
for you and like that's a thing
especially when dealing with my rape
okay I know this is like but when you
know you therapy and all that like it's
very difficult sometimes for people to
hold two truths yep
and I think that my I have a deep deep
rooted understanding of holding many
truths at the same time about the same
situation and so that translates to my
parenting in that like my decision to
involve my children in my social media
because it is a part of my job mm-hmm at
this point be something that I want them
to like have an awareness of and be able
to feel like they have agency over and
and also something that they're not
afraid of yeah
and moving forward I don't even know
what it's gonna look like for them as
teenagers and especially cricket cuz
we're talking like she'll be she's six
so in ten years what's the thing gonna
be it's not gonna be Instagram probably
it'll be something else yes but I want
them to learn through me and through my
stuff and like how to kind of try to
navigate that world mhm and and what
sharing is appropriate what's
inappropriate and I like we had a little
bit of a fail with my eleven-year-old
she has a private she's private a
tik-tok thing you know just for her
friends yeah and she did a tick-tock
that wasn't it like wasn't mean it was
like expressing her just go it wasn't
that funny
well it was it was like it was a fail we
take it down just didn't get a lot of
like and get a lot of likes it was not
if no but but but she did she did
express an emotion she was going through
about a fight she was in with a friend
hmm
using that like post Malone song like we
talk in different circles or whatever I
don't reckon I don't either
um but used to like the friends name in
the tick tock you know and I was like um
boy well that's not we can't do that
that's not acceptable like you can't put
your friends on blast on social media it
was like thing to me it was less she
felt stupid like she's stupid she felt
embarrassed about it
and it was taken down it was like
brought to our attention from the other
girl's mom or something yeah the other
girl yeah the other girl like told the
teachers and the teachers told us the
whole thing I mean we just used to
gossip
we it's just ghostly it's you know
friends would call three way they would
three-way call me and one girl would be
quiet and then the other go like tell me
what you owe my gosh do you know what
Lindsey said about you tell while you're
on the phone what did you what did you
what do you want to say about Lindsey or
whatever and then you would say the
thing and then Lindsey would be like
you're gonna worsen hang up the phone
and your bus that was a required tapa
was a strap
but yeah but like so yeah so part of my
social media like in my involving my
kids which is that I ask their
permission since they were very very
little I will if we take a picture and I
want to post it on Instagram I'm like
hey I want to post this picture with the
caption
can I do that like just so you know lots
and lots of people will see it some of
them are our friends but a lot of them
we don't know personal mmm-hmm and
Bertie went through a period of time
where she was like yeah now mm-hmm
I don't want to be mmm absolutely not
and I totally respected that and then it
was like upsetting to me that some
people would comment like it's clear
which daughter's your favorite no it's
just clear which daughter is like yeah
sure I don't
post that whatever who cares yeah post
up it just looks like you're old it
looks like a only post cricket cuz bird
is just Marv she's she's older and she's
like more protective of her of her
personal of her persona compromised your
brand guy isn't like I'm on board with
it because who knows what kind of
partnerships we're gonna land next year
for her what are you gonna do if they
want to act I don't know I'll be
supportive of them I want them to be
happy and fulfilled and feel loved and I
do think a little bit that like if we do
our jobs correctly they won't but yeah
you know what there's also like an
inherent thing in some kids I see this
with some of my other friends whose kids
are who are like performing kids of
famous people or whatever and they are
already they're just they come out like
singing and dancing and yeah yeah you
know it's an epigenetic it is mm-hmm I
had it from my mom yeah people don't
talk about epigenetics enough I know you
guys have heard me ramble on about it
but sort of the neuro chemicals that
you're pummeled with when you're in
utero basically kind of decide a lot of
things about your life if your mother is
stressed out a lot while she's pregnant
with you you're gonna get an addiction
to cortisol and adrenaline the same way
like a crack baby is addicted to crack
when I worry about that with birdy
because I was really stressed out when I
was pregnant well that's not true
I was really chill when I was pregnant
with her I was really stressed out after
I had her yeah so you're good you're
good I mean if you're reading your faces
that was probably before she was reading
her face if you were stressed like right
after you had it yeah
I mean the first three years it's really
about eye contact and you were with I
remember her constant I remember one
time I came over when you first had
birdie
and I came over and I went to go touch
her and you really get some Purell on
your hands like you had the pure-pep
yeah I wasn't her I wasn't really I was
a rack like it's what your first baby
everyone is I think so I wish there was
a way to like teach people how to raise
their second child first right it was
the second one you're like yeah take her
I don't she's fine I got to do this
other thing she's gonna be great you
know I love you I love you you're so
cute oh my gosh okay bye like I just was
so much more chill with cricket the
first child is like is it gonna die is
he gonna die it just coughed is it gonna
die I mean yours just like so much more
anxious well the whole but they do
get more eye contact and they do know
that they're gonna be cared for the
whole first year of any baby's life as a
mother
your brain is is like I don't you know
half of your brain is tasked with making
sure that that kid stays alive for the
first year that's right that's it and so
everything that you do in the back of
your head that is like running always
mhm
always mm-hmm and so that's why I like
new moms are wild yep I mean you have
escalated hearing like you can hear
better as soon as you get Burton you
just become sort of like superhuman
we're animals I mean we are animals
which is also my theory about like
increased anxiety everywhere well yeah
we're not designed we're not designed to
be in tribes over a hundred people that
yes but here's my other theory because
all these kids all these fucking kids
you have like crazy anxiety yeah and so
my theory is actually about climate
change and that were just animals yeah
and like much like your dogs will go
nuts before an earthquake mm-hmm our
earth is literally dying yeah and we on
some yeah very primal level know it and
so everybody's hippocampus is like going
crazy yeah and like freaking us all out
yeah ever so we and so we're putting it
on all these other things yes I tweeted
the thing the other day like I feel like
everything is a red herring like
literally everything every you know
they've gone extinct red herrings have
even got red herrings are dead but good
news is the good news is anxiety does
motivate you to do things so that is why
the next generation is probably gonna
fix this fucking middle I hope but I
hope so but but this is what I'm saying
about red herrings like so many people
are like I have so much anxiety it's
about social media
it's my FOMO I was like yeah not your
fucking FOMO yeah the world is a bonfire
yes yes look like let's do something
about it and then the people at the top
the castle that are like actually in
charge of all the actual shit yeah it
could change yep climate change don't
feel it because they're dead inside
that's correct they went numb they're
not yea power changes your brain yeah no
like yes awareness that I was feeling
anything yes we are like out of our
fucking minds we're crazy people but the
truth is they're the fucking crazy
people and the things
Media that I think a lot of people get
half right is the stuff with social
media causing anxiety your phone already
produces cortisol because your brain
thinks it's the Sun the light in it so
it's like your brain is already
producing for you bro use those glasses
but no I know I got them really hmm
I put my phone in grayscale and then in
dark mode as well but it still doesn't
work I'm an addict so it's always gonna
be a thing yeah meet him you know but
social media does cause anxiety for the
reason we don't know what causes anxiety
is because our brain is designed to rank
ourselves so we're designed to anytime
an animal walks into a room they
basically have to rank themselves they
go okay like you're more powerful to me
you're less powerful to me okay you're
the person whose ass I need to kiss in
order to be safe if shit hits the fan
you're the person that's gonna make sure
I'm safe so we're designed to do that
like a couple times a day
the problem is what we do on social
media is most of us while people follow
people who are more powerful than us ask
for a celebrity is rich people famous
people gorgeous people whatever so we're
constantly ranking ourselves every time
we go on social media and we're pretty
much always at the bottom of the ranking
and our primordial brain is basically
like you're the least valuable person in
this tribe you're the one though you
know reject your at least you know the
one they leave behind you know so that's
really what ends up happening so you
stop producing as much serotonin last
thing and then I'm gonna let you go gift
it's best if you've gotten if I'm gonna
buy Busy Philipps a good gift what's it
gonna be I'm obsessed with gifting I'm
obsessed with how to show people you
love them and I think personal yep
period
okay like something personal that I will
like be like oh my god your remember
that's so crazy oh this girl this girl
sends you know I love crystals long as I
have a rockin R cuz I've you know lived
in Los Angeles long enough at this point
I'm just like draped now dressed like a
rich psychic I love I that's what that
is my aesthetic
I had a friend my friend Eliza she was
like a mom friend of mine that I'm that
I love and she was like my only goal in
life is at some point I just want to
like be dressed like like a therapist on
the Upper East Side and I realized that
mine is like like a rich psychic yes I
just want to look like a rich psychic
like a gold digger in Santa Fe yeah a
hundred percent
I love her okay so but anyway this
girl's sent me this as a gift because I
like love her crystals and I'm you know
whatever and they're so beautiful and
she inscribed on the inside of it
know them yourself oh that's which is
from my book I said like no one's gonna
tell you the realization I had is like
no one's ever gonna tell you the things
that you want or need to hear all of the
things that you want and need to hear in
the moment you just have to know them
yourself that's so true oh and it was so
sweet I don't think people know how easy
it is to get something engraved I don't
think I think of that enough things
Remembered at the mall get it where are
we getting things engraved yeah we
didn't do that Manton is the expert on
all things mall I love them all Benton I
love them all oh he worked in the mall
for years I love them all I think he
still secretly does what where'd you
were around I worked at Sephora and I
worked at Mac I just told him II had to
stop having brands oh now he's was at
Babson Beverly Center no oh so this was
in Tennessee yeah this is peak mall Oh
peak mall Oh bendin just got out here
what have you a oh my god I didn't
tonight it was a unaware of that part of
the Germany was opening for me on the
road and I was like do you want to be my
sis I did literally missed that chapter
you literally live in Tennessee yeah and
then he was a PA on a pilot that I did a
couple months ago and he really got a
rough entry in time fun not fun no
mm-hmm and on time yeah I do think we
could sell a show with that man ray oh
it's super that we don't haven't done it
yet Oh Ryan Seacrest's why would we do
that I just produced a reality show yeah
and we I mean obviously we're a part of
it we're characters well obviously we're
casting ourselves like but I do think
that like the two of them together
trying to make shit happen for us is
like just why do we hate money so much
why haven't we done this I don't it's
weird too much money might be unhealthy
maybe that's what we're doing not for me
because I want to make a billion dollars
so that we can give it that I want to be
I want to become a billionaire so that I
can save the world
yeah it's my know me too cuz I gave all
my money way yes I think we I think
that's the whole thing you have to you
have to give all your money away guys
gonna get it if we don't that's my thing
that's my thing about snatching bags
right now is that like if not me it's
just gonna be some fucking guy correct
correct and I'd rather be the I'll be
the fucking guy
what are you chair say I am a rich man
mom I am a rich man marry rich man I am
rich ma'am no you know that my mom said
that - I didn't know that was a share
thing I thought my mom made that up no
but I don't think she did but I think it
was I think cher had said it first but
my but like some woman when I was a
child said like I commented on her
jewelry or whatever and I and she was
like oh your daughter has very expensive
tastes you better marry rich and my mom
said busy he's not gonna marry rich
she's gonna be rich your mom is it about
us red flags in people just a couple so
our listeners have something to take
away here with the red flag I mean yeah
like like I think like like that I mean
that's the only I can I'm doing them
things I'm gonna rise to grab your face
like someone up like a lifestealer a
vampire because I wear of vampires
beware of people who ask too much of you
too quickly I think it's more like
people who steal your fucking life yeah
that's happened to me leeches yep yeah
like I don't know I've been friends with
people and then all this and I'm like
wait but how are you at this place
this is my place and then wait how are
you at this this place - oh my god and
wait this very very specific weird place
tonight
what yeah it's happening and there's a
different why are you wearing 9 crystal
necklaces right and there's a difference
between being like a pert I am a
connector yes you are insulated well
you're a very there are literally you AR
the Kevin Bacon mm-hmm of sort of hell
in terms of everyone kind of knows each
other yeah through you I feel a lot of
and I'm and I'm happy to make
introductions and I love and there's a
difference between like connecting
people and then having and then being
taken advantage of by people that's
right yeah and I have had that in
relationships before where people have
just totally fuckin taken advantage of
me in a way that like doesn't feel good
and then starts to make me feel like
what anxious and we
and like what's happening why am i wait
why am I not at that dinner party where
it's literally everyone I induced yes
and I also had this thing where I used
to like I don't I don't think someone
can use you for too long without your
consent you know and I used to allow
myself to be used in a pretty extreme
way and it took me a long time to
ascertain one that was kind of happening
yeah it's a it's and that's another
thing as we are just aging beautifully
speak for yourself I'm Benjamin Button
you're also like you're so much younger
than me 37 honey that's like a bud
that's like a million years younger than
me you're not I'm 40 that's three years
yeah that's Amathus not our strong suit
but I look back at 37 I was just a
different person I'm so much
better-looking today I you know what I
have always and I remember I was on a
movie set with an actor named Charlie
Hunnam mm-hmm and we talked about how
beautiful you are for like a couple hour
what it was really I never told you
about that yeah like I think you are
bewitching Lee beautifully nice but I
wasn't always I really came into it I
don't know I think I think it's actually
true I think if you look back you'll be
like Oh interesting
no okay but I do think I think I will
look better as I age I grew into my face
mmm-hmm there's that maybe I did but I
also I don't know well I have yeah my
other theory part two I think that I
think that your outsides catch up with
your inside I think so too and I said
that a lot when I was little because
that milk commercial I had it memorized
oh yeah um and I would practice it in
the mirror for hmm and I really think
that something like worms into my brain
and I do think that I have like tried to
live my life in a way and I've tried to
do the work and I were tried to be self
aware and I've tried to be a good person
a good friend and show up for people and
show up for the world and show up for
everything and like also take care of
myself and like do all of the things and
then I think I got prettier that like
I'm serious it's pretty powers not
there's nothing injective I can't hear
you say that yeah no I can't people say
that no I mean I'm saying it yeah I just
said it's like nothing injected no work
done I think I just like literally my
outsides caught up like that is pretty
an you drink more water than anyone in
American it's guys yeah its hydration it
is well because and also Olay I think I
also because I get accused of having
facelifts so often facelifts are like I
don't know what people think I have like
cheek implants and chin implants and all
sorts of shit I do have breast implants
pretty open if I have plastic surgery I
am going to pose I know I only well know
only thing I like have gone back and
forth about is like getting the tummy
pull thing because I had the two babies
and I have the skin like I can work out
I love my like I'm so proud of my strong
and spotty but I do have that skin stuff
and I go back and forth like the
feminist in me is like fuck it that's
even the pros are the proof of your life
whatever and then the other part of me
is like but just let's stretch it I
think the most feminist stated it's to
do whatever the fuck you want whenever
you want
I waited so long to get my breast
implants because I was so worried that
I'd be a bad feminist if I did and and
being a good feminist doesn't mean
you're making yourself suffer because
you're worried about the judgment of
others totally you know
agreed do whatever the fuck you wanna
but I also then I'm like am I I can't be
like Cher's mom and clueless and like
dieting a tummy tuck but you're not
gonna you're not you won't that's Mike
you're gonna go to something I'm gonna
give you a guy but I also I did get more
attractive I think and I as I I gained a
bunch of weight and then it was like you
got a facelift I was like no I'm just
not gone yeah starving to know that's
another thing to either it's fat I
really always I really never did suffer
really from any sort of deprivation in
terms of like fat and then you learn how
to put makeup on that's the other thing
when they put side by side me and
they're like Whitney before and after
it's like well I just didn't know how to
fucking use makeup and then it I look
better and I have better lighting like I
learned how to pose on red carpet yeah I
learned how to pose on yeah that's the
other thing some of them
from early days are shocking shock for
both of us
I've seen my Joe I never could put him
up but from maid of honor from that
premiere in New York I could have that
could've been well audibly pregnant I
wasn't though I was like as okay
you knew the joke about this right yes I
do I was two weeks ahead two weeks ahead
of Michelle Monaghan mm-hmm pregnant
right she was still hiding her pregnancy
you couldn't she was this is not a joke
you can look at the picture shows
premiere I was five months pregnant I
remember you in a Nicole Miller dress
yeah your stylist cover me
oh really dirty really yeah I didn't
have a style I never had a guy was the
best never had a set Rob is too busy for
me now he is like Jennifer Lopez yeah
he's got a huge I know he's he did my
special but he's so busy always feel bad
asking him but the only stylist I've
ever had is Carla Welch and I met her
after Bernie was born and I didn't have
anyone to help me with the maid of honor
premiere and you like I wanted that
dress and you're like look I've got a
guy hold up I know Rob's en garde he was
one of my best friends at the time he
was I was a writer on Last Call with
Carson Daly don't mean to brag and he
was working on that and we were just
really good friends wild I know I love
you I love you we went so long but we're
probably to cut a lot of this out if we
start having a panic attack afterwards
what else what I'm gonna say mark says
you still with Whitney it's Whitney I'll
be here for another four hours I don't
know where I am
unlike she gave me the personality it
sounds like Jamie Foxx she made me drive
so far away like Jamie Foxx Whitney
that's why I got so upset I'm projecting
I love you guys
good for you Busy Philipps you already
follower subscribe subscribe
don't write elephants season oh yeah
don't do that
hmm don't ride a baby elephant never
elephants don't get it
[Music]